makes it look like we're on a radio show
yeah
check it out the joe rogan experience
train by day joe rogan podcast by night
all day
yes ladies and gentlemen welcome back
randall carlson how are you sarah
i'm doing well joe you freaked out the
entire uh podcast population the last
time you were here with your stories of
cataclysmic disasters and
and uh the uh ramifications of
asteroidal impacts and
just the just the the evidence that you
presented was a real
uh mind [ __ ] as it were
well uh what can i say well
i apologize to all the listeners out
there that um might have had nightmares
no worries i knew that was going to be
the case though i knew
after the first time i met you we had
that long conversation in atlanta
i knew uh once you sat down for three
hours on a podcast and opened up about
that stuff it was really gonna uncork a
lot of people's domes
well you know ironically there's an
upside to the whole thing maybe we'll
have time to get into that a little bit
today
yeah definitely so tell me you just
returned from a long excursion with
graham hancock
if you want to bend that thing like that
towards your face or probably work a
little
yeah there you go like this yeah there
you go um you just return from a long
excursion with
graham hancock you guys were on the road
and what was
the nature of your trip well we were
i was taking graham on a tour showing
them some landscapes
we would i could call him the landscapes
of catastrophe
because he's doing his um sequel to
fingerprints of the gods
and you know when he came out with that
book in 1995 he was
theorizing that there had been this lost
civilization in prehistoric
times and you know the critics the
the gist of most of what the critics
were attacking him on
when there were considerable attacks on
him as a result of
some of the things he put forward in
that book was that well if there was
this
you know great civilization that had
existed in you know
somewhere back in prehistory where's the
evidence of it where
where is the where's the pottery you
know where are the
the carvings where where is the the
infrastructure
that would have uh existed and
you know i don't know if he really had
an answer for that other than the fact
that you know there had been
cataclysmic events that had intervened
between then
and now but he wasn't really specific
about what the nature of those
catastrophes
actually were um and a lot of additional
research has come out since 1995
that basically opens the window onto
those events that basically separates
our modern history
which you know the recorded history goes
back
five or six thousand years um you know
when we look at
at the emergence of modern civilization
we would basically trace it back to nine
or ten thousand years ago with the
emergence of
of um you know agriculture
uh the dispersion of languages uh the
first cities
and so forth when we go beyond that a
few thousand years
we're in a completely different world
and i mean so completely different that
it's almost
unrecognizable from our modern world
if we started recreating maps uh
going backwards like taking snapshots of
the planet
every millennium going back what we
would see is that
going back to seven or eight thousand
years ago the basic configuration of our
planet would not change much
once we get 11 12 13 000 years ago
the changes become profoundly dramatic
we start seeing sea levels going down
hundreds of feet we see
massive ice sheets covering north
america and europe and
and lots of other enormous changes
beyond that is what i consider to be
deep history
because as we may have talked about in
our last interview you know we modern
humans have been on this planet for
150 to 200 000 years at least
you know if we go back say i think the
oldest modern human skeleton
ever found was named homo adaltu
and he dates to about 180 000 years
roughly
if we think of a generation of humans as
25 years
that's 7 000 generations of humans right
now so the question is is
what were we doing for all those
thousands of generations until somebody
finally
realized hey you know what we can plant
crops we can
you know we can build cities we can form
communities
you know we can invent language etc etc
well my contention is
and i think the evidence that's
accumulating supports this
interpretation that what we're really
seeing
seven eight nine thousand years ago is
not the origins of civilization but the
rebooting of civilization
you see what i'm saying and when we go
back and we realize
that modern history is separated from
deep history
by this extraordinary series of events
that transpired between about 11 and 13
or 14
000 years ago once we begin to recognize
how
extreme these these events were in
remodeling our planet totally remodeling
our planet
it then becomes obvious to us why there
is not a lot of hard evidence for
whatever went on prior to these to these
events
and there's been some things that
they've found since then that have
really sort of
made graham hancock's theories become
more and more palatable to even
mainstream scientists
yes like go beckley tapping exactly
exactly go beckley tepe
uh gunang pedang these are apparently
uh structures that were built at least
11 or 12 000 years ago
and i'm waiting to find out the um the
most recent
uh ideas on them i think that probably
they go back much older than that um
because from what graham told me they're
just only in the preliminary stages of
being excavated
so yeah i believe quebec tempe is less
than 10 percent excavated right
yeah yeah so this is this enormous ruin
that appears to be
you know late pleistocene ice age
in india in age that apparently was
deliberately buried
um which is interesting brings up a very
interesting
issue why would they deliberately bury
it and they know it's delivery
deliberately buried because of the
uniformity of the age of the dirt is
that what it is
i questioned graham on that because i
wanted to know if it was
because the first thing i thought to
myself was it could be natural
because i have seen so many sedimentary
deposits caused by great floods
graham assured me that that it was um
that it was human that that it was
deliberate it was not
because if it had been buried by floods
or water there should be internal
stratification it would be very
obvious um i've been giving it some
thought
and and you know what occurred to me was
this and and i um
ran this by graham but i i haven't
gotten a
response from him on this but i started
thinking if it was deliberately buried
why would they bury it then i begin
thinking
what we talked about last time when we
were talking about the tunguska event in
siberia when you had this massive aerial
detonation
you know that was about a 15 megaton
explosion okay now that's
equivalent to our biggest hydrogen bombs
that used to be in the american arsenal
and it's just because of an asteroid
that that blew up in our atmosphere
about a
150 foot diameter asteroid which is not
that big
really relative in the cosmic scale of
things
the the the point though is it was
moving really really fast
you know is moving you know a rifle
bullet let's say on average is about
a thousand feet per second right a an
asteroid coming into the atmosphere is
going to be 20 or 30 times
that velocity so it carries an enormous
kinetic punch when it hits the
atmosphere
it explodes because of the fact that
the earth is not actually absorbing a
lot of that
energy it's dispersed widely through the
atmosphere
now think about this particularly during
the height of the cold war
in order to protect our missile silos
our super hardened command and control
centers what did we do with them
put them on the ground put them
underground we buried them exactly
and that began i began to think perhaps
could
could explain why it was buried in order
to preserve it
um against the possibility of of
some kind of an aerial burst or or you
know some kind of a
a highly energetic event that seems
a weird thing for 12 000 years ago no i
mean what what
we have really no evidence whatsoever
that anybody is capable of doing
anything like that
that long ago well as i i think on the
contrary i think
i think that what we see at the very
beginnings of recorded history
is an obsession with the sky you know
that's one of the points that graham
brings out in his work you know is that
that humans
our ancestors of of 10 12 13 000 even
you know
much sooner than that had had a um just
an obsessive concern with events in the
sky and
you know all of these ancient structures
whether we're talking about stonehenge
and i'm sure it's going to be the same
case with gobekli tepe
when we look at these these uh this
infrastructure from
uh you know like the mesolithic period
uh through the neolithic period from you
know six
five four thousand years ago three
thousand years ago what we see is that
there's this concern with astronomy
you know you the the astronomical
alignments that are built into these
structures
actually allow some pretty sophisticated
uh observations of of events happening
in the sky
and and we can maybe pull up some stuff
here that i've brought today to look at
that but um
yeah i think that um it's highly
plausible that people back then could
have because
think about this again to try to put
this in context
how many generations ago was the primary
mode of human transportation horseback
not that many four or five generations
ago pretty crazy pretty crazy
now think seven thousand generations are
you going to tell me then all of that
trans all of that time all those
generations
of humans that have the same presumably
intelligence as our own because they've
got the same brain size
that they're not going to be able to
come up with some kind of a
a transmitted tradition some type of of
um you know the idea of somehow of
culture of civilization
of language of uh you know that's my
point is that there was so much that has
been lost and once we understand how
dynamic this planet really
is it'll become clear to us why we don't
have the hard physical
record of of things going on 20 or 30
000 years ago
to put it in perspective for people who
have never studied ancient egypt
cleopatra the pyramids
if you if you look at the date of the
pyramids the
the cleopatra is closer to us
yes than the pyramids were the cleopatra
yeah yeah which is
nuts it's like you stop and think about
that like wait a minute what they was
that old back then and they've found
these little tiny
airplanes inside the pyramids these
little
little miniature you know carved
airplanes
that look like airplanes and someone's
people have tried to
say well no they represent birds that
doesn't look like a bird at all i mean
they have a rudder
and they look like planes well yeah and
you know there are traditions
particularly the vedic traditions that
are full of
descriptions of flying objects yes the
vimanas yeah exactly
so what is that you know i'm not gonna
proclaim
unequivocally it's it's it's airplanes
but at the same time we got to keep an
open mind about it and
and the point i'm trying to make is that
yeah there was so much time that
transpired
all kinds of things could have happened
that that have basically been erased
right um and and hopefully by the end of
today's
interview you'll have a better clear
idea of specifically what some of those
things really were
so we're talking about a potential
civilization of maybe
tens of thousands of years of growth and
if we're looking at what we're
what we have from the beginning of the
dawn of civilization and we believe
mesopotamia somewhere around 7 000 years
ago
from that till today we're talking about
maybe double or triple that
was lost in these gigantic cataclysmic
events maybe 15
20 thousand thirty thousand years of of
human beings inventing things
people building upon the inventions of
others yes expanding
and then all of that boom wiped out
where rubbing sticks together again to
start fires and then whatever
memories are left people have to rebuild
a generation or two ago
it was easy to dismiss ideas like that
is fringe science right
today as we say here in 2015 it's not
nearly so easy to dismiss that anymore
particularly what we now know about the
history of this planet and how truly
dynamic it has been
and um that we have in effect been sort
of blessed
the last six to ten thousand years with
a relatively stable climate and i'm
going to show you some graphs here
that really will blow your mind um that
really will
will underscore how significant some of
these changes have been how profound
some of them have been and once we
once we know that begin to incorporate
that into our thinking we realize we're
gonna have to kind of reevaluate our
models of of prehistory
okay well we have a new setup now so
with the tricaster we're gonna allow
randall to take control of the situation
here if you're just
listening to this this might be one of
those podcasts where
if you're one of those people that
listens to it on a commute you might
want to go back and
check out the uh well vimeo or youtube
or
those are the ones that ustream is going
to give you hd now too right
we we do some people don't even know we
do a hd video of this podcast as well so
what is this uh oxygen isotopes in
greenland oxygen isotopes in greenland
yeah what we're looking at here
this goes back to the early 90s when um
you know glaciologists and
paleoclimatology
guys who study ancient climate extracted
these ice cores from the summit of
greenland and the reason they went to
the summit was because they were looking
for the most undistorted ice core record
that they could find previous
uh ice core extractions had been near
the perimeter of the of the ice sheets
and
and and there the ice flow is is much
more dynamic so
um there was more distortion in the
record so what they did was they went to
the very center there was a european
team and an american team
and without getting into the into the
background basically the ice sheet there
was almost two miles thick it took
five years to drill through it was so
miles
thick yes yes just think about how far
like looking
how far two miles away it's like what is
a plane a plane's a mile in the air no
no
well a jet's going to be about 30
thousand feet what's a mile 35
000 feet a mile no you remember this
because it's going to be important
number 5
280 feet is a mile is a mile right
now the tallest building in downtown l.a
is probably not
over 800 feet thousand feet at the most
no
um i'm not sure i did look it up at one
point what the tallest building was i
don't remember what what it was i know
the tallest building in atlanta is a
thousand and sixty feet
and um you know two miles you'd have to
think of ten of those stacked on top
right each other to get a
two mile thick sheet of ice that's
that's an amazingly
huge mass of ice right right and and
and that's pretty much the summit of
greenland right and what we're looking
at on this
on this graph here if you if you go down
the left side of the graph
this is it's the surface and then down
here this 1500 you see right at the
bottom that's 1500 meters
right 1500 meters you figure there's
about 3.28 feet per meter so
that's going to be 45 it's going to be
yeah close to 5 000. so this is this is
1500 meters totally a mile yeah a little
less than a mile
over here on the right is is the time in
thousands of years before the present so
as you go down
right there there's a thousand years you
go down there's two thousand down at the
bottom you see ten so that's ten
thousand years ago
now basically what what the oxygen
isotopes do they're a proxy
for temperature change adjacent to the
ice mass right
and if you look at this these are
snapshots basically taken like every 10
years
right and what you see here is that the
is the temperature is oscillating back
and forth
back and forth it's uh two to four
degrees
centigrade now to put this into context
the concern
you know we got into this somewhat last
time the whole
issue of global warming and and i know
that in in some of the
the feedback we got some of the the most
critical comments came from people who
didn't like
me undermining this whole concept of
global warming induced catastrophe right
right
what we see here though is clearly that
the
the climate this is the ten thousand
years that we're talking about here is
called the holocene
by geologists it's oscillating back and
forth two to four degrees
centigrade every every 10 20 30 years
right so we're we're talking about a
degree
that has changed basically in the last
century to a century and a half
right which which really almost wouldn't
even show up here you see
but we're going down as we go down we'll
see if you go to the right
that means temperature is warming as you
go to the left it means it's cooling
right and so as we go back down this is
through the holocene
we're going through here and if you look
there's some interesting stuff going on
right here at about 8
200 years ago there's a really there's a
spike of cooling right there
and that was very very significant
cooling i mean that was
probably uh caused the
glaciers worldwide to start growing
again for short for a couple of
centuries after they had
basically disappeared at the end of the
ice age so this was a very um
significant event right here and then as
we get down right here at ten thousand
you see it starts deviating to the left
it starts deviating to the cooler
i'm going to go to the next slide where
we take this graph and we turn it
on its side and what i've done here
is you see this is this is the present
right here
and this is basically 10 000 years ago
over here on the right side
and and i've drawn a level there's a
level green line in here to kind of give
you a
a comparison and you'll notice something
here's this 8 200 year ago
cold spike right and then as we're going
along here
you'll notice something that the the
general amplitude of these
oscillations starts increasing as we get
closer to the present can you see that
yeah yeah it gets bigger and you'll also
notice that that it's dropping
it's dropping below that green line it
and that means it's cooling
so in the last 10 000 years we went from
a period of considerable warmth
in the in the immediate post-glacial era
and then it began to cool off around
6000 years ago
5 000 years ago and as it began to cool
off
the temperature oscillations begin to
increase in magnitude
okay which actually contradicts the
computer models that are saying the
amplitude of the oscillations is going
to increase as the climate gets warmer
what we actually see from the greenland
ice cores is the opposite of that
and it's right here in this graph but
what's really significant about this
is when we go back beyond 10
000 years ago whoa and we see this jesus
christ yeah for folks who are listening
there's a
giant change i mean we're looking at
little tiny
you know maybe millimeter left right
left right left right
up until this point now we're looking at
huge
changes huge changes wow catastrophic
changes
of temperature yeah and and here we're
going back this is look notice this is
between uh
11 right here roughly 11 600 years ago
and about 14 000 years ago look at what
happened right here you can see
right around 15 000 years ago the
climate is is actually if we took this
thing out of here you can see there's
almost a
a trend upwards that gets interrupted
right here
boom instantly boom overnight jump
overnight overnight yeah and in fact
um what has happened is if you go back
through the literature of of climate
change
and you read the the estimates of how
long it took for the planet to shift
modes from
full glacial to the interglacial like
we're in now
50 75 years ago it was a thousand or
more years
thousands of years when radiocarbon
dating came along in the 50s
it began to compress and what happened
is that if you look in the
80s they're talking about perhaps a
century several centuries
now comes the greenland ice cores and
other ice cores and other proxies deep
sea
cores and so forth and the correlation
of all of this evidence
and it goes from centuries to decades
well
as the ability to perceive these changes
with ever
greater precision and ever greater
resolution has evolved
it's gotten to now where the change the
climate change that took us from glacial
to interglacial happened in less than
five years
and that's what we're seeing right here
in this graph what
that's what we're seeing so 2010 glacier
2015 done ice age over
the glacier yeah bear in mind now that
there was a considerable lag
between the actual the the the
manifestation of the glaciers because
the glaciers didn't melt that quick
right because they're so huge right here
that started imagine that we had a
big chunk of ice we had an ice sculpture
here right
and if the temperature is you know 31
degrees it's not going to melt
if you turn the temperature up to 70
degrees right
we could turn the temperature up in the
matter and it could warm up the room in
a matter of
hours or minutes but it's going to take
a while for that ice sculpture to melt
there's going to be a lag
right although the change that led to
that meltdown was
virtually instantaneous you see right so
but
in that in that period in this interim
what we're seeing right here
there was an extraordinary right here i
think if i go to the next slide i
think let's go to the next one
yeah i'm going to zoom in here so you
can see this
there were two massive warming spikes
one right here you can see that we're
down here in full glacial mode right
there
and then boom right there there's huge
spike of warming now what does that
represent when it comes to like
temperatures
uh that could be on the order of
well that would be about 10 to 12
degrees centigrade which should be about
18 degrees
fahrenheit average temperature which is
a
crazy crazy crazy change because we're
scared of two degrees
we're scared of two degrees and here
we're looking we're scared two two
degrees centigrade here we're looking at
five
six times that much in a matter of a
couple of years
you see at this point
we don't really have an explanation for
this that's why i get really frustrated
when somebody says to me oh the debate
on climate change is over
no no no we're we're in the infancy of
understanding the climate of this planet
and when we look at stuff like this you
see um
it it really drives home that point and
you can see here
right i think what people are saying
when they're saying that the debate on
climate change is over though is whether
or not human beings
have had an impact on it in current
times no question we have had an
impact right now no question of what the
debate is right
well if you say that the debate is about
have humans
had an impact or not i think that
there's no debate
humans have had an impact what they're
looking at though in your mind
is one aspect of a very
multi-dimensional issue yes
yes exactly and and
my my concern is is that we're going to
get so focused
on carbon change on carbon chains that
we're not looking at
any of these other factors isn't that
what people do though
we concentrate on one aspect of things
and it becomes like almost like a
cultural meme and then it spreads and
this is all people talk about
yeah and so many people i guarantee you
that we're upset at what you said have
not researched climate change at all
they just have parroted the words of
people that they've heard on television
that are experts
well you got this well 97 right i agree
well if you look into the origin of that
um it's pretty contrived it really is i
mean how you come up with that and and
we could do an hour-long discussion on
that and i don't really think
we want to get into that today but i i
really feel like i should write an
analysis of that the source of that 97
so-called consensus so that people can
really see where it came from
in a nutshell basically it goes to three
or four pieces of research
um some surveys that went out um that
were slanted right from the beginning
such as
do you feel that humans have had an
impact on climate
yes nobody disagrees with that see you
can go through all the whoever these
so-called deniers are i have looked and
looked who's
who's denying is there any climate
scientists
on any anywhere on the spectrum that
denies that the climate changes or that
denies that humans have had an influence
on the climate
and i haven't found a single one so in
other words these deniers that you hear
about you know the climate change
deniers
they don't really exist there are those
who criticize
the consensus view right that the
dominant mode of climate change is being
induced by humans
and they are being shoved into this camp
of climate change deniers but they're
not
they're absolutely not climate change
deniers and when you look at stuff like
this
you know a lot of these guys who would
question the so-called anthropogenic
climate change consensus
are guys who've done this work now this
work is how old
well let's go this goes to the uh this
goes back to the to these
the this work that i'm showing you here
was published in 93.
the the the the um the greenland ice
sheet project
and the um the greenland ice sheet
project
into greenland i forget it was grip and
jisp
the two uh it was a european and an
american team they spent five years
drilling
so these are the most accurate proxies
we have at in hand
and they're pulling tubes of ice is that
yeah like a cylinder yeah like cylinders
picture maybe six inches in diameter
so you have like a circular cutting
thing they have a circular cutting drill
that extracts these ice cores
and for the last 20 years they've been
analyzing the ice core you know it took
five years to get them out and it's been
you know 20 years now of analyzing what
they're telling us
so before they had all these ice cores
when they were saying that this
climate change took thousands of years
was that just guessing
pretty much based that was based upon
actual empirical observations of
ice glaciers receding as a result
of the modern warming because you have
to understand
up until about the middle of the 19th
century we were in the middle
of what was has commonly been referred
to as the little ice age
and and this is another thing that's
important to put into context
the ice the little ice age was in two
phases the earliest phase came on in
about the mid 1300s
then it warmed for about a century in
the 15 1600s and then the second phase
came on
during that time the glaciers worldwide
began to grow
and most of the evidence today suggests
that during the little ice age glaciers
were bigger than they had been
in 10 000 years so around the middle of
the 19th century around 1850 give or
take a decade or two
the climate began to warm out of the
little ice age and glaciers began to
recede
right now if we look at glacier
recession that's going on right now and
it's been going on for the last 10 or 20
years
what we see is it's basically a
continuation of the recession that's
been going on
for 160 or 170 years
right so it's important to establish
what's our baseline when we're comparing
modern recession of glaciers
bear in mind that our baseline is we're
starting from the glaciers being bigger
than they had been in 10 000 years right
so the i think then we have to
understand that that that little ice
agent in fact had some pretty serious
consequences for civilization
um we can see that there were two
periods in the last 2000 years there
were two periods
of global cooling one of them occurred
in the sixth century
uh it actually now can be accurately
dated to
occurring between 536 and 544 a.d
which is a very interesting time this
was basically the time that historians
have have for
for decades said this was the onset of
the dark ages
it's also the time during which all of
the arthurian myths and the grail quest
stories are placed you know arthur
arthur's desk
death is is traditionally placed at the
battle of cam land
or kamlon which is usually dated at
about 540
a.d which which basically culminated
this
quest for the grail right what was the
now the grail stories themselves were
set down in writing
uh between about 1180 and 12 30 a.d
in this really interesting time during
the middle ages at the same time that
the
great cathedrals were being built um
when the cathar movement was at its
strongest when the night
knights of the temple were at their
strongest
when kabulism schools were flourishing
in spain when the troubadours were
making their their circuits around
europe uh you know
spreading news and entertainment but
really probably
carrying uh esoteric information to the
initiates that had the key
to the to the secret language that they
used it was very interesting time
but it was in that 1280 to 1180 to 1230
that the
uh that the grail stories were written
down now the grail stories actually
refer back to this period
of the arthurian days and the quest for
the grail if you recall was that the
that the land had uh succumbed to blight
it had become a wasteland england had
become a wasteland
and the idea of the grail was it was the
grail
not only restored the wasteland it
restored the king because remember the
king whether it was king arthur or braun
or on fortas or the fisher king
there were different names in different
stories it was the same deal
he was sick he was in decline he was
wounded the wound wouldn't heal
um he was debilitated and the only way
to restore him was to find the grail
bring the grail back allow him to drink
from the grail but the
the grail was also the means of
restoring the wasteland to fertility in
in
now here's where it gets interesting is
that the dendrochronologists
who who study tree rings have been
looking at that period
exactly in that period that the the
tradition places the the
grail quest and have discovered that for
about eight or ten years
forest growth in the northern hemisphere
almost came to a screeching halt
and this has now been well documented uh
mike bailey has has done most of this
work
basically showing that there was a a
serious global cooling that took place
during those years um and the historical
record of that seems to confirm because
there's
multiple descriptions uh you know from
irish monks and so on
describing how for weeks at a time the
sun is not visible
um that you know that its darkness has
come over the land that there were
reports of these mysterious fogs and
then there are multiple collapses of
agriculture
okay so as a result of these
multi-year collapses of agriculture
because of the cold and the dark and the
damp
people got malnourished and then you had
famine
as a result of famine people their
immune systems became
weakened and then in 542 a.d
you had the onset of the justinian
plague which wiped out
maybe a third of the population of
europe whole whole villages disappeared
as a consequence
now these events pretty much followed in
sequence
you see the cold brought about the
collapse of agriculture the collapse of
agriculture brought about famine famine
brought about weakness
and as a result boom you have plague
now it took european civilization nearly
three centuries to recover from that
now what brought about the recovery was
the return of warmth to the world what
is called the medieval warm period
and between this began really to occur
in about
900 a.d this the sea ice
began to retract back well inside the
arctic circle which opened up the sea
lanes between
northern europe iceland and greenland
and so it was this
period of time that the that the the
vikings were able to sail
to iceland and then sail to greenland
and actually establish
uh colonies on the west coast of
greenland greenland and farm where now
the ground is perennially
perennially frozen let me try that again
perennially
frozen right so it was clearly a warm
period and what happened was
if you look back now at the studies from
that medieval warm period you see that
agriculture rebounded so many people had
lots of food to eat
actually studies of skeletons show that
the the stature of humans during this
period of time
increased by four or five inches on
average from what it had been
during the dark ages and um
now europe started becoming wealthy
again because the basis of all wealth
basically was
was agriculture was food right without
that not you don't have anything else
population began to expand enormously
you see other things going on
life spans increase infant mortality
decreases all of this stuff has been
well documented in a whole variety of
studies
well after about a century and a half of
this
warmth with the with the uh concomitant
wealth that came along
european society was wealthy enough to
undertake this
extraordinary cathedral building phase
you see where you had literally hundreds
of thousands of highly trained highly
skilled craftspeople
working on these things you had
essentially when you began to look at
the cathedral building phenomena
it required the basically the
mobilization of
the whole of european society behind
this enterprise
because you had to quarry huge amounts
of stone you had to transport these
stones you had to carve the stones
you look at the statuary the stained
glass which is
exceptional in its in its refractive
properties that really have still
not been mimicked to this day the way
the stained glass was able to refract
light so that
it gives the appearance of of not the
light coming shining through the glass
but emanating from within the glass
and and you could go on and on with this
the the the carpentry skill the
engineering skill
the astronomy that went into these
structures
all of this combined basically shows up
basically in a historical instant and in
what's interesting is the the scarcity
of of evidence showing
what preceded this how did these
who organized this who raised the money
who trained the craftsman you know this
is
there are references that to this in
history but really
you know there's no explicit detailed
discussion where we can go and trace and
say okay this is this is how it happened
you know but it's important to realize
that this was a consequence of the
uh of the uh you know the expansion of
of
of wealth in european society that
that was able to allow this to happen
and that's as a consequence of the
warmth
the warmth of the earth and what we see
is that
the cathedral building era comes to
a sudden termination in the early 1300s
and if you go and you travel around the
cathedrals you'll find that there's in
many cases you know
the record suggests that it's almost as
if
in the middle of their work that workmen
laid down their tools and left in some
cases
this is why there were so many
cathedrals of the the great ones that
weren't finished okay but what you see
is that exactly concurring
with the cessation of cathedral building
within a within a few decades anyway
was the onset to the little ice age and
the return of the cold
in this first phase of the little ice
age uh again brought about
agricultural collapses it brought about
famine and then you had the black plague
that showed up i think around what was
it 1330 1340
right in there again decimated the
the civilization of europe so you can
see i mean
if we look at the historical record what
we see is the times of
of global warming have actually been
times of
advancement in civilization now of
course that
that would have its limit i mean we
could get to you know at some point
where we would get
too warm but so far what we've seen
we're
at this point well within the range of
natural variability that's the
why is this never brought up by anybody
but you i've never heard anybody else
discuss
this this very controversial subject
it's controversial because everyone's so
fixated on
global warming being about it's it's
there it's there for anybody who is
willing to do their homework
you know and if somebody uh goes on my
website or whatever and says
what are your sources i'm glad to
provide multiple multiple sources
going back i've been i've been
collecting this data for decades you
know and it's there
and i have to ask the same question why
are we ignoring
this evidence you know why are we well
the i think we're ignoring it because
climate change has become a
political agenda rather than a
scientific question
you know and so because there are
political factions that are lined up
behind it
um you know the inter intergovernmental
panel on climate change is now looked at
as as being the
the ultimate source for data on the on
the climate
and bear in mind they were created by
the united nations framework convention
on climate change and given the mandate
of go out there and demonstrate that
humans are causing climate change so
right from the very start that was their
mission
and they were not told go and look for
natural causes of natural climate
variability
study the human and it's important i'm
not at all saying it's not important for
us to
study our own effects on climate
but it's going to be dangerous i think
if if we neglect
you know what we're seeing right here on
these graphs of this graph that i'm
showing you because that's clearly not
carbon dioxide see
if we're told and we have been
repeatedly told that carbon dioxide
concentrations in the atmosphere held
relatively steady at about 280 parts per
million
right prior to the industrial revolution
and only
subsequent to the industrial revolution
did carbon dioxide start going up
well if we assume just for the sake of
argument that that's correct
well look at this graph what we're
saying is that if carbon dioxide held
steady at 280 parts per million going
back hundreds of thousands of years
as al gore has actually stated and as
many others have stated
it's not carbon dioxide driving those
climate changes is it
well it can't be that it can't be no if
that's the case and that's hard science
this is hard science here it is right
now it's hard science as well
you're looking at something really crazy
some event
yeah yeah that's my point now the
alternative is okay are we saying if
if carbon dioxide is the dominant driver
of climate change
and that's what we're seeing here then
what that basically says is that there's
some gigantic unknown reservoirs of co2
that have outgassed into the atmosphere
which again undermines the so-called
consensus view because
so far the consensus view consensus view
states that
the client that co2 is only increased
because of burning fossil fuel
so this graph is the real inconvenient
truth
this graph that's well put yes this
graph
is the real inconvenient truth and when
we look at some of this i mean
right there that is a major global
warming right there
because this dashed line represents the
modern temperature
like the 20th century average is this
dashed line
that dashed line but what year are we
looking at right there
right here this is between 100 and 150
000 years ago
and that's a giant jump that's a giant
jump
i mean so what what does that represent
as far as degrees and temperature
oh well let's see that's probably going
to be you know 15 to 18 degrees
fahrenheit
whoa yeah right there so that's you know
again 15 to 18 times greater than the
than the presumed temperature increase
of the last century
is there any mainstream i shouldn't say
mainstream scientific explanation for
what that is no well it's called the
eemian
it's called the eemian period it's an
interglacial period but even within the
interglacial period you see that there
are these
massive oscillations massive cooling
coolant
warming again yeah and so there's a
variability
if you're saying the warming is between
it's 18 degrees is that what you said
up to that so the cooling you're talking
about almost
that much in the other direction in the
other direction yeah and
you're talking about this over a period
of just a few decades well
as we get back this far we don't have
the same degree of precision as we do
when we're we're here um perhaps yes
but we're not sure but we do know that
these
changes that we're looking at here that
terminated the last ice age
were just in a matter of a few years
yeah for sure
and the instantaneous nature of those
is what you focus on when you start
talking about
asteroidal impacts and things along
those lines that that
is something that we can explain that's
something you can point to
by default there doesn't seem to be a
lot of
other things that we can invoke to
explain what we're seeing right here
and there's absolute evidence that we
have been hit
multiple times we're going to get into
that yes yes
and and that's a big part of what what
graham's book is
this is amazing when you look at the
ancient history i mean it's not even
ancient as far as i mean they were human
beings living
sort of like us oh yeah but how much
different the
climate was like it was so [ __ ] up
well i'm not sure about the west coast
but i know on the east coast
there were you know swarms of icebergs
stranding like off the coast of south
carolina
for example you know there was no great
lakes
because the great lakes were under
thousands of feet of ice you know new
york
boston detroit um seattle
portland or not so portland but seattle
twin cities chicago all of these areas
were under thousands of feet of ice
thousands of people and we're not
talking millions of years ago we're
talking
you know 12 13 000 to
25 to 30 000 years ago that's incredible
it is and in sea levels we're basically
in round numbers 400 feet lower
than now which essentially exposes the
entire
cotton most of the continental shelves
and i'm going to i've got some some
interesting graphics here to show you
uh what what continental coastlines
would have looked like
there was an article that i was reading
recently about aborigines and aboriginal
tales
of uh of the lowered
like lowered sea levels yeah that
they're starting to correspond now with
actual climate data and
understanding of what the sea levels
actually were at that time these are
stories that are supposedly 10 000 years
old passed through oral traditions
these traditions to me are just
beyond valuable you know up until very
recently
they have been considered basically just
you know
interesting in the in the in the
anthropological or psychological sense
but had no real
hard scientific um credibility to them
now i think we're beginning to
reevaluate them there's a an
archaeologist
archaeologist by the name of bruce
massey who's been doing some very
interesting work
in for the last 20 years analyzing
many of these ancient myths and
realizing and and putting
out there the argument that these that
these myths and these legends and these
epic tales
uh encode really hard scientific
information
that we can extract from them and um
talking about global changes
and astronomical events and so forth and
and
um so and i've been a believer in that
for a long time you know and this is
you know one of the premises of graham's
work is that
that the myths and the legends actually
have a great deal to teach us beyond
just
the psychological orientation of our
ignorant pre-scientific
ancestors you know but yeah you the good
point you make there
um when we look at this graph basically
what we're seeing here is that coming
out of the ice age you can kind of see
that we're coming up here and then we
have this
first massive spike of warming and then
it seesaws back down into this full
glacial cold
this is called this period between these
two green arrows is called the younger
dryas
which is named after a polar wildflower
that had disappeared
in northern europe and then suddenly
came back again it only grows in polar
environments dries octopatella
so the younger driest compared because
there was an older driest too
but it lasted now the dates are placing
it from roughly 12
900 years ago give or take a few decades
to 11
600 years ago so this
spike of warming right here is 11 600
years
now if we look at the next one here this
graph
basically goes to a different realm of
evidence
and what this shows is the average the
rate
of sea level rise you see
now oceanographers and marine geologists
have have been studying
there's there's a number of different
ways they can correlate this information
they can look at actual evidence of
submerged shorelines right they can look
at at changes in the
in the flora and the fauna that have
that have lived in the oceans
they can look at coral reefs there's a
lot of different things
that they can pull together to see
how rapidly sea levels rose at the end
of the last ice age
and again a generation or two ago the
assumption was
that there was a smooth continuum of
rise that took tens of thousands of
years
right to get us from minus 400 feet up
to what we are now at the present level
what this graph shows is that there were
two massive spikes of
melt water introduced into the oceans
into the global oceans at the end of the
last ice age
and you can see the first spike called
melt water pulse 1a
is the biggest followed by another one
meltwater pulse 1b
if we go back to this graph right here
those two spikes of glacial melt water
and sea level rise coincide with this
warming spike and that warming spike and
you can see
how this warming spike seems to be the
most intense
followed by this one and we see that
meltwater pulse 1a
is the biggest so what this is showing
is that the
the rise in sea level was not as smooth
it was like
whoop and then womp again so there was
something that caused all those glaciers
to melt within
just a very short amount of time
geologically speaking yes a geological
instant
exactly what's further interesting is
when we look at this graph
this is the late pleistocene mortality
graph
in each square represents a fossil
specimen
of an extinct mammal you know could be a
woolly mammoth
could be a giant ground sloth could be a
saber-toothed cat could be the giant
cave bear
roughly 120 species of
mega mammals that lived during the ice
age
went extinct right at the end of the ice
age and basically
what this graph is showing us here is
that
you probably can't read this here so
i'll interpret it for you if you go back
to here
the left side represents 50 000 years
ago
and here where where the cursor is
that's 40 000 years
30 000 20 000 and you see that
as we're going along here each one of
these squares represents the finding
of a fossil of an extinct mammal in the
in the fossil record what we see from
this graph
is that when we get to between eleven
and thirteen thousand years ago
there's a massive spike shoots through
the roof
this demise of these animals directly
coincides
directly coincides with this right here
directly
now what we what we're dealing with is
that for 50 years the dominant theory
has been is called overkill or
blitzkrieg
and this theory basically states that
bands of paleo-indian hunters came
across the bering land bridge
slaughtering every animal that they
encountered along the way
and somehow within less than a thousand
years swept from siberia down to tierra
del fuego
and killed off every woolly every
mammoth in the world
and presumably every other of the
extinct mammals and that has been the
dominant theory that
that humans caused this mass extinction
and personally i think that's just
absurd
you know because for one thing based
upon anthropological studies
there were possibly more woolly mammoths
in the world and there were people for a
while
um you know you have to assume that the
blitzkrieg was so instantaneous and so
all encompassing that there was no time
even for the mammoths to
to reproduce of course the overkill
hypothesis
basically addresses itself only to
woolly male only to mammoths wooly
mammoths were one species of four
different species of mammoths
but what about the other roughly 120
species what about the the giant
armadillos and the giant beavers and the
american pleistocene lion that was as
big
big as a horse you know the list goes on
and on and on and on and these animals
all basically disappeared
during this spike that you see right
here and that spike falls exactly
between these two warming
spikes and between the two sea level
rises so all the data
all points the same time period yes
wow and so what i'm saying and this is
this is uh you know basically consistent
with
what what graham's saying in his book is
that this this what we're seeing here
this episode basically represents a
curtain that has come down and obscured
150 000 or more years of deep
human history and basically has lost
that history to modern perception
but now once we understand that yeah you
know what
the uniformitarians were wrong to reject
all ideas of catastrophism you know
because
in the original in the early days of
geology the the founding fathers of
geology
were catastrophists they went out in the
field
uncovered uncovered unencumbered
by dogmas and doctrines and so forth
they looked at the evidence in the field
and concluded that there had been
catastrophic episodes and this is you
know baron von cuvier
sedgwick murchison if you'd go back and
you all of these guys who basically are
considered the godfathers of
modern geology they were to a man
catastrophist
uh james hutton uh lyle and
playfair came along and basically
proposed the idea of uniformitarianism
the present is the key to the past very
powerful
uh working uh idea is that we can look
at stuff that's going on today
extrapolate backwards and try to figure
out things that happened in the past
when
we don't have a an eyewitness account
right
very powerful but what what happened was
is it it became so entrenched as dogma
that anybody who invoked catastrophes
was considered
um basically fringe because in the early
days
some of these guys like sedgwick for
example he was a theologian he was a
traveling minister who went around and
in in his travels to you know convert
the the
the people to to christianity he would
see
the stuff and he would you know place it
within the context perhaps of being
noah's flood right and they would place
it in
some of not all of them some of them
would place it in a in a biblical
context right
so when they were attacked basically the
the substance of the attack was well you
guys are trying to
bring us back to the days of biblical
literalism and science has moved beyond
that
we're not here we don't want to talk
about catastrophes or great floods
deluges
we're through talking about all of that
that's all been discredited
and what you see is between the early
1800s
at with the the beginning of geology
earth science to about the 19th century
what you see is a steady decline
you know some of the older guys die off
they're replaced by the new guys who
have now
basically taken control of the
university curriculums
and they've been indoctrinated into this
idea of a strict gradualism
and that any deviation from that strict
gradualism is is
uh heresy basically so by the time we
get to the 20th century
you had this reigning uniformity
reigning gradualist
dogma that had been imposed upon all
earth science
and anybody who deviated from that was
immediately kicked out of the club
and this is why when j harlan brett's
came along in the 1920s and proposed
that there had been these gigantic
floods in the pacific northwest
you know the geological community
basically said ah
get out of here we don't want to hear
about it we know that that couldn't have
been
uh just because we know jay harlan brett
continued to to document
uh exhaustively document from the field
that that these floods were very real
his critics said well you don't you
can't provide a source for these floods
therefore they didn't happen now bear in
mind that all of his critics his
his most vocal critics had never even
gone out
to actually look right and uh
graham is going to he has got a great
section in his new upcoming book
describing
that the ordeal that brett's was put
through he finally prevailed
ultimately um most of his critics died
off
you know he outlived he lived to be i
think 98 so i think when he was 96 he
was given the penrose medal which is the
uh the highest honor of geology and you
know he said he was very grateful but
the only thing he
was unhappy about was the fact that he
all of his critics had died off so he
didn't get to gloat
over them so but um
but so what happened was you had the
younger geologists come in who are who
are more open to that and and what you
see is between the 5th 1950s and 1960s
you have a transition going on where
where they're
beginning to accept that these great
floods had happened
but but what they did was they took a
modern
example which is glacial outburst
floods which you know we've witnessed
dozens and dozens probably hundreds of
such cases in iceland particularly
alaska british columbia uh the himalayas
where you have
particularly going back to the little
ice age when the glaciers began to
recede
in the mid-19th century you had a lot of
what are called pro-glacial lakes formed
or lakes bodies of water held in by the
melting ice
and then eventually the ice gave way and
the the water rushed out in the form of
a flood the icelanders called it a
yokolops
okay so we have a modern example so
what they did was in the 60s and 70s was
they said okay
guess what we've got now evidence that
there was a huge
body of water a huge lake in western
montana
it was held in by an ice dam that ice
dam gave way
all of this water gushed out over idaho
and in southeastern washington down the
columbia gorge to the pacific ocean
and caused all of these this amazing
erosion and
sedimentation that harlan bretz was
documenting
never mind that we have to extrapolate
up three orders of magnitude from modern
examples
right never mind that the modern
examples are utterly
minuscule compared to what brett's was
looking at
that has become the dogma to explain
these floods
and it's still the the entrenched dogma
as we speak now
i am trying to demolish that dogma i
want to show
that these floods were something much
grander than they have even
imagined and that the source of them was
not actually a big
glacial lake but was was what brett's
originally
originally theorized was that there was
something that caused a rapid melting of
the ice
but then his critics said well there's
nothing that could melt the ice as fast
as you're requiring for your flood so
again your floods didn't happen
but his floods did happen and they were
on an enormous
inconceivably vast scale and this is
what i was taking graham out
to see firsthand because i felt like for
him to
to really have a handle on this
this information and this this insight
into the catastrophes that that
basically would have terminated his
mother civilization as he called it that
he should see this stuff in the field
for himself because
you know as they say a picture is worth
a thousand words
well going out in the field and
experiencing this directly is worth a
thousand pictures
and and so he's gonna incorporate that
into
into his book and i would like to say
about that book that um
based upon what i know and what he's
shown me a bit of what's going into the
book
um i'll i'll proclaim without uh
any equivocation that i think it's
probably going to be the most important
book that's come out in the 21st century
because it's it's opening a window onto
this story like no other
single source of information credible
information wow
that's a big that's a big statement this
whole thing is so mind-blowing and as
mind-blowing as your first appearance
this this
chart especially is really freaking me
out like looking at the mortality all
the animals the mass extinction event
that must have taken place
one of the things that always bothered
me about that idea that human beings
killed off the woolly mammoths is that
they found these
vast fields of uneaten mammoths where
there was
thousands of them that had died almost
instantaneously
yeah which is just that doesn't make any
sense like what did they do they
went on a mass killing orgy of of
slaughter and then just decided not to
eat any of them
well you know the field evidence itself
is inconsistent with that idea right
here this is an example this is one of
the
many mammoth cemeteries and and what
happens is that you can see here that
you can see from the shoreline see that
there was a flood the
the river rose up to this level and then
when it rose down it left this
in its wake and what you see here like
this is bone counting
at the barrel like mammoth cemetery in
northern yakutia siberia
identical deposits are found throughout
the thamer peninsula
and what we see here is these massive
bone deposits that have been
showing up for the last couple of
hundred years
every time that there's you know a
thawing or a flood
uh or these things are washed up on the
shore of the arctic ocean
you know what we see is that there were
huge huge herds of woolly mammoths
grazing where now the the plant
material is only two inches high so
clearly
it was a completely different climate
there you know what's interesting is
that you
you had in siberia able to support herds
of woolly mammoths
at the same time that half of north
america is buried under two miles or
more of ice
how is that possible just a totally
different atmosphere still puzzling over
that i have some ideas but
you know until i can test these ideas a
little further
so without ice core samples is it
impossible to figure out what the
temperature was in siberia at that time
no no they can figure out basically
based upon fossil
plant remains and you can see that in
some cases the tree line was hundreds of
miles further north
than it is now and that's clearly if
you've got trees
forests growing now where you know 13 or
14 or 15
000 years ago it was permafrost you know
it was warmer
clearly so there's still whoa
what is that 19th century scene showing
ivory floor of the london docks covered
by
thousands of mammoth tusks from siberia
this is a a
drawing obviously yeah predates uh
photographs
yeah for hundreds of years thousands
of mammoths entombed mammoths and
mammoth tusks were being exhumed
from the siberian permafrost thousands
and thousands and thousands of these
and and basically to me you look at this
this is just in your face evidence that
this was not
humans doing this you know it was not
humans that were
were slaughtering these mammoths and
burying their remains
well it would it's the instantaneous
nature would almost
it would almost be like people had
figured out some new thing like they
figured out some
some like a doom gun you know
they jumped and they shot the whole
the doom gun well look at look at the
near extinction of american bison
what brought that about trains and
high-powered rifles right it was a
technological
major technological advancement that was
able to bring about the
near extermination of the americans
there's actually a guy that i'm going to
bring on the podcast soon to discuss
that his name is dan flores who's been
is in
a big chunk of his intellectual career
studying this
and what he believes is that the bison
had a massive population jump
that was directly correlating to
smallpox epidemic
on the native american people and that
when
the united states uh when we look at the
united states history
and the big stacks of wooly mammoths or
excuse me the big stacks of bison skulls
we always look to like that was a very
unusual population of bison that existed
because
the plains indians had experienced this
massive extinction event and then
when they had incorporated the horse
like the horse
and the the apparently the american
indians native americans rather
were on their way to extripating the
bison even before
we came along but then they died off in
this massive
death scenario with the smallpox and all
the different diseases
that the europeans had brought over here
and then
the mammoth population or excuse me the
bison population had
grown like almost unnaturally it'd been
much larger than it ever been in the
past
and that's when the united states was
established and that's when all the
western european immigrants had come
along and started
killing off all these bisons it's really
a very interesting
subject and it's an interesting idea
it's plausible i
i haven't looked into that
you know i i just assumed and maybe
maybe wrongfully but i had assumed that
the
bison population had been relatively
stable
i am not convinced though that that
there was this massive die off of the
native american population yet
i'm not convinced maybe well because i
haven't looked into it yet but
but you know one of the things i have
seen is that um the assumption there is
predicated upon that the europeans
arrived and brought the diseases that
that native americans had no defenses
for but
the thing is is that you know there's so
much evidence now
showing that you know there were lots of
uh
um explorers and immigrants to the new
world
prior to the arrival of the europeans
you know whether with the chinese the
phoenicians and i'm not necessarily
saying that's credible
none of it's been proven but there's
some interesting data out there that
suggests and there are a number of books
written
that again i haven't accessed it i i so
so i'm not going to
sit here and pretend that i'm an
authority on that because i'm not but
but if some of that turns out to be
credible it would suggest that there was
a lot more interaction between the
native american population and other
groups around the world
which if true to me
kind of somewhat undermines this idea
that they were
um you know completely susceptible
to the introduction of these you know to
these foreign diseases
but but again i will i've got an open
mind i'll wait and see
i'd like to see what his what he says
i'd like to hear his
his uh um his ideas for anyone
interested
he has a paper in the journal of
american history it's called
bison ecology and bison diplomacy
the southern plains from 1800 to 1850.
i just looked for it online you can
there's a preview that's available but
to download the entire paper
or book i'm not sure which one it is
it's 19
yeah and what's what journal is it in
the journal of
american history from september of 91
and like i said he's working on a new
book right now
and uh i'm trying to get him to come in
but it's just it's very difficult while
he's in the middle of uh
you said september of 1991 yeah yeah i
can probably access dan
flores is his name and uh
well just the information that i got
about it was pretty mind-blowing
but uh sounds interesting i wanna i
wanna i wanna know more
thank you for that joe yeah please um
now let's let's go back to that photo
that you have on your desktop that you
were gonna explain to me but we decided
not to talk about it before
uh the podcast because it's so
incredible
that you said this all this incredible
change that we're looking at the the
geological structure
all that took place within just a week
yeah let's go to this we'll come i've
got that we'll we'll come to that
um this is uh
this is a satellite photograph taken
from about 500 miles up
and what you see here this is
southeastern washington and what you're
looking at here
is part of what's called the columbia
basalt plateau
this is part of the the terrain that
that we crossed when i was with graham
um
what you see here is that you have an
area of
if you look here you can see the the um
oh
differentiate between the pixels and the
actual squares that
like you see this red area down here is
area that's actually being farmed
and it's in because this is an infrared
photograph and so
what happens is is that the areas that
are being uh cultivated will show up
warmer than the surrounding areas
this is this whole plateau is covered in
this stuff called loss
l-o-e-s-s and it's a type of very
fertile
soil that has a rather mysterious and
controversial origin we
won't get into that right now but in
some places this lust layer is hundreds
of feet thick
over a dark basalt bedrock that is a
result of
of these massive outflows of basaltic
lava
that that came out that extruded between
about 6 million and
16 million years ago right
the the hot spot that was the ultimate
origin of this basalt is now where
yellowstone
is which so you can make that connection
here the yellowstone
uh super volcano super volcano yeah yeah
it
in but what you have here
is that you have the lighter areas is
where this lost top soil still exists
and the darker areas is where the the
underlying dark basalt
has been is showing through because the
lust was
washed away so what this is is is your
typical
the geological term is anastomosing
and basically that means a branching
flow pattern of the water
and you can see that very clearly here
that the water
came off of this river which is the
columbia river up here and flowed over
the landscape
and washed away the basalt and left
these
gigantic channels in its wake and
there's more over here to the to the
east
there's more over here to the west
and if we look at actually this
let me go to a different program here i
think that'll actually have
some uh that actually i think has the
picture in it that you
are seeing now what we're looking at
here is what's been called the missoula
flood
right named after the town of missoula
montana missoula is in a basin
that was part of this hypothesized giant
lake
that that presumably caused this flood
right
and again there was an ice dam that
there was this ice dam the ice dam broke
and as soon as this thing comes up i
will be able to show you
some slide here we go let's see here we
go
it should be coming up right here while
that's coming up
we'll look at this slide right here
because this will kind of give you
uh a picture of the earth
as it was during the height
of the ice age
so wow that's pretty deep the the sheets
of ice go
pretty far down that's amazing canada
didn't exist canada didn't exist
wow yeah poor canadians yeah
well yeah and you know and you know
the ice part of it is you know a lot of
the in the midwest
now a lot you know the farming belt of
america
is basically you know growing out of the
fertile soil that the ice scraped off of
canada and dumped
you know down in minnesota and iowa and
wisconsin and so on so
um you know someday they may want that
back
but we're not going to let them have it
it's fascinating when you look at that
that there's this big ice cap but then
the areas around
it no ice and why why was that
well that's one of the mysteries again
like over here in siberia
you can see over here this is where all
the woolly mammoths were
giant herds of oldie mammoths and it
appears like it may have been
warmer than now during the ice age which
is very odd
there's some ice up there is that what
we're seeing yeah there's some ice up
there
sporadic glaciers but nothing like what
we see in northwestern europe over here
this was called
the fenno scandian ice sheet and the ice
sheet over
north america actually consisted of two
ice sheets the lauren tide
which was centered over hudson bay and
the cordiary which was centered over the
canadian rockies
and in this particular slide you can see
uh you can see here this was the
cordieran over here
on over the canadian rockies and this
was the lauren tide was much bigger
see and and then there was an area
between the two
right here which has been theorized as
at one point having been a corridor
called the ice free corridor and
migrants from
paleo-indian migrants from siberia
would have come across alaska and down
through this corridor here to the lower
united states and ultimately down here
to
south america and it was that
group these groups of bands of
paleo-indian hunters that according to
the
the overkill or blitzkrieg hypothesis
wiped out the
the the mega mammals as they as they
passed by
um that's just
let's see okay there we go okay so here
this kind of will show
uh the coastlines
of the uh of the world during
the uh during the ice age and uh
let me just escape out of this
so that we can uh zoom in a little bit
and look at it closer okay so
here would be
as we see now
and this is modern coastline this is
modern coastlines and now i'm gonna
i'm gonna jump to this is actually only
300 feet lower than now
and
quite a bit different let's let's just
look at the united states
north america that's amazing there's a
lot more united states
yeah now check this out okay now here
here's north america as it is now and
you see up here this is what's called
this is the bearing straight right here
between alaska and siberia
right during the ice age this whole area
was exposed because of the lowered sea
level and we'll go
one slide further and you will see take
a look now watch what happens up there
in
beringia boom wow so it's all
land it's all land and it's connecting
north america to siberia
and that's all drowned well i didn't
understand that see i always thought the
bering strait was an ice mass
i thought it was during the ice age that
there was some sort of
yes that it was ice but it's not it's
land
it's land wow and it's not glaciated
and it was home to these extraordinary
herds of mega mammals that ranged over
these
thousands and thousands of square miles
i mean the drowned area is bigger than
modern alaska
so how how long ago is this well this is
you know right at the end up until the
end of the ice age
you know between like 14 15 000 years
ago 14 50
000 years ago no glaciers in this area
this is all just land and there's
animals living in it and people are
walking back and forth is i mean
essentially it was a continent i mean it
was connected
it was all one continent it was all one
it was all one continent wow that's
amazing
and not the coastlines of the world look
at florida down here
see it's double the width of the modern
peninsula
yeah it's enormous and it's so close to
mexico too it's almost like a little
yeah a little boat ride
now here is indonesia and you know where
where
stories which i don't know how credible
they are but you know there are stories
like lemuria in the pacific and all of
that
again i don't know how credible those
are i think the atlanta story actually
has a little more credibility we talked
about that last time somewhat but
here's the modern and you can see the
light blue is the is the coastal shelf
area
right now let's go back drop we're going
to drop sea level 300 feet
and then you'll see here the enormous
change
whoa so again enormous areas of land
were drowned by the rising sea levels
remember this now when we look at the
rise of modern cities in modern
civilizations where did they first show
up
where's the coasts on the coasts right
at the mouths of rivers on the
coastlines
and and during the ice age where would
have been the most obvious
prime habitable real estate you know
down close to sea level right so if
there were cities built
you know if they were thriving
communities during the ice age they're
now 400 feet under the water
it's so amazing that all of these
stories of
the floods the epic of gilgamesh noah's
ark
yeah that all of these stories seem to
really correlate with with all this data
i mean they all
seem to coincide that's exactly the
point
it's so weird okay you know most people
would think about the story of noah's
ark
oh it's just some crazy old horseshit
but
most likely this they're basing it on
something that happened very rapidly in
their
area yeah now of course we're
most familiar with the story of noah's
ark you know because of the
judeo-christian tradition but there are
hundreds literally hundreds of stories
from
all over the world that parallel the
story of noah deukelian
uh zisithrus utnapishtum manu
that list goes on and on of these
culture heroes
that somehow had foreknowledge of this
impending disaster
and were able to take steps to preserve
themselves their family
some diverse cross-section of of species
um which and they all have this you know
similarity they all parallel now
my way of looking at it is this okay we
now know from the hard geological record
that massive floods have taken place on
the surface of the earth
massive floods right beyond anything
that we have even imagined
right up until a decade or a few decades
ago
they're real okay on the other hand we
have stories and myths and legends
repeatedly it's probably the most
ubiquitous of all the stories that we've
inherited from the past is the story of
this
gigantic world destroying flood that
occurred
right now on the one hand we have the
geological hard geological record which
shows
there were giant floods then we have
these epic tales and myths from all over
the world
about giant floods do we now dismiss
those floods those those stories out of
hand and say oh that's just
superstitious pre-literate you know
pseudoscientific nonsense
i think we'd be making a big mistake to
do that now
if we accept that those flood stories
and maybe they have been altered through
the time and through the telling
represent something real what about the
other
other uh elements of the story the fact
that in so many cases
there was somebody that had
foreknowledge do we dismiss that
out of hand as well you know or where
does that come from that there was
one group of people small group of
people that saw this thing coming
and prepared for it and others who
basically
paid no attention maybe they were just
preppers maybe there's the preppers of
ten thousand years ago the preference of
ten thousand years ago
that explains it right there
one last slide quick here here's here's
europe and look at the british isles
right now we'll drop sea level
no british isles that's incredible see
that's what i was saying earlier when we
started our talk i mean the world
of 15 000 years ago was so dramatically
different than our modern world
that you know it's it's almost difficult
to conceive until you start
looking at things like this and this is
all during the ice age
yes and so the melting of the glaciers
just changed
everything everything and this is why
human beings were absolutely alive
absolutely absolutely no question human
beings
were alive yes okay
so we'll start looking at some of these
pictures here this is from western
montana you know it says
in genesis 7 19. the waters prevailed
exceedingly upon the earth and all the
high hills were covered
i want you to take a look as you can see
many mountains
in in western united states if you know
what you're looking at
that have this on them you know what
those are those horizontal lines
they look like like where the shore
they're shorelines
exactly they're shorelines that's
absolutely what they are that's
absolutely what they are they're
shorelines
reaching right up to the very tops of
the hills you see and and
basically what you had was you had this
enormous
gush of water filling these mountain
valleys almost to the
mountain peaks and then draining away
and as it drained away
it left the succession of shorelines
etched into the hillside
wow
and all along the pathway of the floods
we're going to see stuff like this
this right this was our first stop with
graham
this is uh la torrell falls this is that
basalt i was talking about
look at this stuff there's layers of
this basalt
well that's you guys underneath it um
i don't think in this bit i think i took
this picture about 10 years ago but yeah
i have pictures of
me and graham under there well you're so
tiny that's so crazy it's so big
right now here's what you've got a
picture joe
picture you've got this nice gentle
valley with a nice
river very pastoral scene you know trees
and stuff
probably you know mammoths and herds of
these animals
grazing along the side of this peaceful
river with gentle
cha valley slopes here comes this
massive flood and we're talking about
perhaps a flood wave 800 to a thousand
feet high
coming through as it comes through it's
ripping up everything in its path
and it what it does is it now changes
the profile of this valley from this
gentle
profile to down cutting
800 1200 feet or more
into the bedrock right so now prior
to the passage of this giant flood you
had streams and
nice little rivers flowing into the main
river which in this case was the
columbia
what happens is after the passage of
this flood wave it sheared off
the sides of the channel so now rather
than a gentle slope you've got sheer
cliffs four
five six hundred feet high these
pre-flood
streams and rivers come up and they're
now waterfalls
and that's what we're looking at right
here in this picture if that makes sense
to you
and and you notice how you've got this
undercutting here
that undercutting only occurs when you
have
enormous intense turbulence in the water
doing this
you see the water doing this will
undercut see this
modern waterfall here had nothing to do
with the creation of this cliff
this cliff was cut again probably in a
matter of days to weeks by the passage
of these giant floods
and there's dozens of these waterfalls
that are left
they're called and these are called
hanging valleys they can be produced by
glaciers but they can also be produced
by
enormous intense flood waves
this is your typical no wait a minute
not typical
this is called this is a a bar
a gravel bar but in this case it's a
boulder bar now if you've ever done any
walking along a river
or a creek or along the beach and you've
seen ripples
in the sand and they're typically you
know if you've got
a water that's a foot or two feet deep
you'll have ripples that are maybe an
inch or two high
what we're looking at here is a flood
bar that's three miles long
it's up to 250 feet above the modern
river
and the ripples that you can see here
are up to
50 feet in height and 350 feet in
wavelength
this was produced again by gigantic
flood flows
and if we look right over here that's a
three-story building you see right there
for scale oh wow so this this gives you
an idea
it's it's features like this that are
just unequivocal
in terms of realizing that this is this
isn't
not pseudoscience this really happened
and
this is there's this date back to a very
specific time
yes to this thirteen thousand years so
it's
healthier everywhere you're seeing this
you've seen it geologically you've seen
in ice cores you've seen it in fossils
yes yes wow this is evidence of the big
meltdown
has anybody ever tried to debate you on
this stuff uh
i would certainly welcome debate i don't
claim to have the final final word on
this but you know here's the thing i've
i've interacted with a lot of geologists
that are studying this
professional geologists that are
studying this what i can tell you is
that in most cases
the geologists that are studying this
it's it's not something
it's basically something they're doing
in their spare time um
most of them are engaged you know either
you know in the uh
energy industry or working for
government for other purposes
what you actually will see here though
when you begin to look at the the trend
in the evidence is that i think that the
geological community is moving much
closer
to a scenario like i'm describing and
right now there's actually a controversy
because you know some of the
the older guard is wanting to defend
this idea of the yokelups this
pro this giant lake uh draining out
there are a group of canadian geologists
though who are challenging that
under uh leadership of a man who may now
be retired named john
shaw who goes back to the 1980s and
began
um a reinterpretation of a very
ubiquitous glacial feature called
drumlands
um and and that were uh
i can show you some pictures of them
here after a bit they're they're very
interesting um
they look like inverted boat hulls and
and it was assumed and they're always
associated with the
the the locations of the glaciers and
the ice sheets
so it was therefore assumed that they
were somehow created by
the glaciers themselves but glaciers
tend to grind
things that they're moving over and
level things off
and scratch them and leave striations
and all of this
abrasion these drumlins are smooth
streamlined features what what shaw
first proposed back in the late 80s was
that they had actually been produced by
water flowing massive amounts of water
flowing under the glaciers and there's a
very similar the the the critic said
well where did this water come from
and he said well i don't know it must
have been enormous sub-glacial lakes
sub-glacial reservoirs
the critics said well there's no way
that that a reservoir as
huge as your floods would require could
have existed under the ice
therefore your subglacial floods didn't
exist
and that was the to me the fatal
weakness in his theory was
to explain where the water came from but
i think now we can't explain where it
came from and you believe it's an
asteroidal impact
again by default i there's there we have
we look at all the possible the cross
section of possible explanations within
the realm of nature
we can go through and we can eliminate
this one this one this one this one this
one and what we're left with is one
that of itself would be fully capable of
doing it fully capable and makes sense
that it would happen instantaneously
that would make sense it would happen
instantaneously any other sort of thing
that would
yes so is there an impact crater that
corresponds to this
timeline well that's what i'm working on
uh trying to find it
yeah and i think i've i think i've got a
pretty good idea but it's going to take
some field research and next summer
i'm planning to do some some more field
is there an idea where it hit
uh yeah i have several ideas you don't
want to talk about it keep it mom
stealing but when i when when it's when
it's time to reveal it
okay let's do it here i would love that
i would love that well
you you've shown several impact craters
you showed a bunch last time you were
here the the one in australia
um that was i believe you said 5000
years ago
yeah yeah and of course everything
hypothetically it hasn't been proven yet
because again
uh some of these more recent craters of
the last ten
thousand years um some of these that
have been hypothesized are
actually on the bottom of the ocean the
berkel crater that i think we talked
about on the bottom of the indian ocean
it's under two miles of sea water so
until we can actually get back there
and and do more in-depth sampling and
examination it'll be impossible to prove
it but uh
i think that the the evidence is
strongly supportive of that possibility
that
maybe five thousand years ago there was
a significant impact into the indian
ocean
that could have caused enormous tsunami
waves now i actually posted one of the
uh
somebody you know uh called into
question
some of the things i had said in the
last interview about tsunamis
and that um that the things i was saying
weren't really tsunamis so i
actually wrote an elaborate response to
that which
is posted on the sacred geometry website
where i've gone into
great detail showing that the evidence
really in the end i think does support
the idea that there had been enormous
tsunamis possibly hundreds of feet high
sweeping over the coastlines of the
indian ocean probably around 5000 years
ago
that could have been the origin of some
of the flood myths
and your timeline where this mass
extinction event occurred
where the massive warming occurred all
that
also coincides with the discovery of
this nuclear glass
all over asia and europe um which is
somewhere
in the when they do the core samples of
around the same area right
around 12 000 plus years ago yes what we
can see
here uh we'll go through a second this
is some of the research
you can see this is this is very typical
the mysterious onset of the younger
dryas now
this is this has been the kind of the
consensus view is that okay
we don't have an explanation the younger
driest remembers that's that interval
between those two spikes
right where you had the warming then the
snap back to glacial cold
and then the warming again so that
interval in between is the younger
driest
so here they're saying the mysterious
onset of the younger driest the 1300
year long younger driest cold
reversal and you notice the dates 12 900
to 11
600 that means calendar years before
present
so what they've done is they've
calibrated this from radiocarbon dating
to which is not necessarily going to be
the same as the actual calendar years
so those dates are very interesting
11 600 years ago you may recall from our
last interview
is the date given by plato for the
subsidence of atlantis
eleven thousand i mean he says that
atlantis subsided in you can
anybody can read this if they want to
pick up timaeus and critias the two
dialogues that he
describes atlantis in he gives that date
9 000 years
before this exile of solon in egypt
which took place in 600 bc
roughly so 600 bc
in rough roughly is 2600 years ago add
that to the 9 000 years and there's your
eleven thousand six hundred
so now what has happened is two thousand
five hundred years ago plato gave a date
which would seem to suggest that
something some something immense
happened in the atlantic ocean
and you had an island complex that sank
perhaps from rapid sea level rise now
2500 years later here's modern science
coming up with the exact date showing
hey there was a massive melt water pulse
into the ocean
at that date now at this point nobody
within mainstream science is going
oh well see he doesn't mention here oh
that's the date given by plato
they don't say that but it's it is the
case that's incredible
yeah that's so amazing now plato that he
was told that right
it was all through stories it was yeah
it was handed down solon handed it down
let's see if i can remember this
the the through depridus dropitis to
cradius the elder creed is the elder to
criticise the younger
then cretius the younger i guess the
socrates
actually at the forum where plato would
have heard it would have been the
socratic forum
where it was told so i think there was
like three generations between
solon and plato the wise men of the time
or the people
that were in charge of disseminating
knowledge back then it was such a
critical job
critical job yes no internet no books
and and
the whole the whole thing was was that
the whole emphasis
was on transmit the oral transmission
had to take place without not one iota
of change
it had to be transmitted from mouth to
ear
unbroken without change without
alteration which has always been the
issue with human beings
hence that telephone game yeah you know
you tell someone something
they tell you something it's but if you
start out and you know
it's going to be the same with native
americans the native american
storytellers have to go through a very
long arduous
term of initiation to show that when
they tell the story it's going to be
exactly
like they heard it that's one of the
basis of modern freemasonry too
we need to get that with today's modern
gossip
yeah they need to nail that but let's
just run through a quick succession here
of some of the most recent research
shock synthesized hexagonal diamonds
in younger driest boundary sediments
whoa now these shock synthesized
hexagonal diamonds
only occur there's no natural known
natural process that will produce them
except for the intense heat and
pressures of a cosmic impact
wow okay and what what year was this
study
oh this has been very recent this is
probably within the last 10 years
there was since 2007 this is probably
around 2011.
there was something that was released
very recently about micro
diamonds and micro diamonds
corresponding last summer yeah and that
also was the same timeline so it's just
like
the evidence keeps accumulating in this
time period that something hit us
yes the micro diamonds the the the
nuclear glass
yes the spikes in warming that's
observable on the ice cores all
correlates the
mass extinction events of all these
animals this is an event
this is an event this is crazy that
you're you're the guy talking about this
event i mean this is really nuts
but not anything taking away from you
but there's so few people
beating this drum that there's so much
information
we're talking about hard data you've
shown on this show
three four different examples of hard
data that points
to this event well see here's the thing
modern science does tend to get over
specialized
and so what happens is the guy looking
at extinctions might not be looking at
you know glacial melting the guy who's
looking at glacial melting
isn't the geologist is not looking at
what's going on in the sky
they're not looking at you know
traditions from thousands of years ago
so
what it does is because of the the power
of
this specialization i mean the
specialization is extremely powerful
but it's shortcoming is is that it's
easy to miss the big picture what that
does
is opens the door for generalists
guys who are just you know people who
are just
i say guys men or women anybody who's
curious about this stuff
to look into it and try to see the big
picture
why am i bringing this well it's just
because for 40 years
i've been obsessed with this stuff and
you know i read two or three scientific
articles
every single day and have done so for 40
years
plus so that adds up after a while and i
don't just read them i study them i take
notes you know two or three
every single day so you figure what is
that a thousand a year
you go back 40 years that means i
probably read something in the order of
40
000 scientific articles from
anthropology geology when i studied
geology and astronomy in college so
you know i have some academic background
in that but
but you know basically what i have done
is tried to piece together
the big picture because early on i saw
nobody's doing that
no nobody's doing it really and some of
the guys that are out there doing it are
not
doing it with academic rigor you know
they're bringing in all kinds of weird
stuff
which makes it easy for the critics to
attack them and dismiss them as
fringe science they're throwing some woo
into the mix
they're throwing some woo into the mix
yeah in fact
the one of the
the the rational wiki uh entry on me
says something about
randall carlson and his woo and that's
all it says
you know so i took that as a sort of a
comment well people love to be able to
dismiss anything that's not mainstream
right that's outside yeah yeah
because there's this cult of authority
you know that's why you hear
somebody says well what does a real
scientist say about this what does a
real scientist say about this flood in
the mike
well which real scientist you know
uh vic baker richard waite uh you know
roy breckenridge you know i've i've read
or talked to every almost every
scientist that's done work on the
missoula flood
you know so i know what they're saying
and what they're thinking
you know and what they've written so so
you know when you say well what do the
real scientists say well
okay let's get a little more specific
who are you talking about because there
are different points of view
you know are you talking about john
shaw's idea are you talking about
you know victor baker's ideas or or or
any of the others well you know and
that's the thing they say that because
they don't really know they've got this
idea in your mind that there's this
authority
that's got it all explained which makes
it easy
right because if somebody's got it
explained then we don't need to concern
ourselves with it or think about it
right right so what i say is okay
forget about who says what let's just
look at the facts
let the facts dictate to us what the
meaning of all of this is
you know and let's look at all points of
view because that's what i try to do
you know i've got in my in my archives
here i've got you know not only
the the research that supports the idea
of
of a cosmic impact back during the
younger driest but the criticisms of it
as well
you know and i go okay how can we
explain those criticisms
and in the give and take of science
that's part of the process
you know that's how it evolves because
somebody puts out a new idea
you're supposed to attack it you know
and then if it withstands
the assault the onslaught that shows
that it's a credible idea
you know it's like a last man standing
sort of thing and i think that the
cosmic impact really is going to end up
being the last man standing
well it seems like there's so much
evidence that you're you're
you're bringing up that's so hard you
know the this the um
the how do you say that word chondrite
chondrite chondrite like mineral from
black matte
i mean all the the the various things
the micro diamonds the
nuclear glass the mass extinction events
the evidence of uh the uh flooding
warming the flooding the sea level rise
all of it all
all this conversion area yeah and this
this is basically saint chondrite
chondrites are a type of meteorite
so this is saying chondrite like
material in other words material that
would have had its origin in space
from the black matte now this black
matte is really interesting i'm going to
show you a couple of slides of it
because this black matte layer
it's black the reason it's black is
because it's so loaded with soot
and what is soot the result of fire
right
so let's let's go through here yeah this
discovery of a nano
diamond rich layer in the greenland ice
sheet so
nobody had looked but when these guys
richard firestone and james west and
james kenneth these other scientists
that are working on this
younger dryas impact hypothesis said to
their colleagues
check out the younger driest boundary
layer 12
900 years ago and see if there's
anything that shows up there
they did and what do you suppose they
found here it is right here a nano
diamond
rich layer so there it is showing up in
the ice sheets
here's new evidence from a black mat
site in the northern andes
supporting a cosmic impact twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago
uh very high temperature impact melt
products as evidence for cosmic air
bursts
impacts twelve thousand nine hundred so
that you know they haven't they're
they're getting closer and closer to
refining the date but it's coming in
twelve thousand eight hundred to twelve
thousand nine hundred years ago
um wildlife
wildfire and abrupt ecosystem disruption
on california's northern channel islands
at the allorod
younger driest boundary at basically
twelve thousand nine hundred
twelve point nine ka means twelve
thousand
nine hundred years ago k you know is the
universal
means a thousand that's great it's all
the same everything
keeps coming back the same date yeah
nano diamond rich layer across three
continents consistent
with major cosmic impact to 12 800
calendar years before present
evidence from central mexico supporting
the younger dryas extraterrestrial
impact hypothesis
evidence from northwestern venezuela and
andes for extraterrestrial impact
the black matte enigmas
evidence for deposition of 10 million
tons of
impact spirals across four continents 12
800 years ago
see it's coming in man it's coming in in
abundance and what's gratifying to me
is i theorize this 25 years ago wow
and it to see now the hard evidence
coming in
supporting a scenario i had pieced
together from all of these different
realms of knowledge is very gratifying
what was the seed in your mind that led
you
to be obsessed for a lack of a better
word
with this not only lack of a better word
i think it's pretty accurate right with
this subject
okay i guess it's time to come clean
i was on mushrooms i was on top of a
mountain well no you're actually pretty
close yeah
you are okay 1969.
oh that's a good year for mushrooms yeah
well it wasn't mushrooms but it was
something
in their family okay okay i'm going to a
rock concert
right in the beautiful summer day early
summer
12 up 12 900 years ago no
1969. right okay
so it's it's on a field next to a little
airport
in uh just out southwest of many the
twin cities minnesota which is near
where i grew up
okay the minnesota river flows through
there
right minnesota river flows into the
mississippi
i think i'll have some slides coming up
here i can maybe even show you
okay so what we have here is that
in the middle of this thing between
bands or whatever i wandered off from
the main
area where the where every the crowd was
gathered to listen to the music and i
walked over
to these 200 foot high bluffs
overlooking the valley of the missis
of the minnesota river now the minnesota
river
currently flows in a little channel at
the bottom of this valley
and i'm standing up on this hill and i'm
looking down
at this minnesota river you know
hundreds of feet below me in this
channel
and three miles four miles
across i see another set of bluffs
matching the ones that i'm standing on
and i had this all i can say is it was
kind of a revelation
that i'm looking down here at this
little river flowing in a channel
and then i'm seeing just a gigantic
version of that same channel
but it's three and four miles wide and i
i just looked at that and it was
almost as if for a short period of time
i got transplanted out of time or
something i don't know how to explain it
you can see this raging river i had this
sense that
this whole thing was a gigantic river
at one time i came away from that with
this
idea planted in the back of my brain and
it
bugged me for years after that right
and it was maybe five six years this is
now into the seventies
there was not a whole lot on
catastrophism available in the seventies
there was you know emanuel velikovsky
one of the forerunners but you know he
he came up with some really wild ideas
that made it very easy for mainstream
science to dismiss him
but he came up with some really solid
ideas too his book earth and upheaval
basically was just a documentation of
all of this geological evidence for
great catastrophes in the history of the
earth
i think he misinterpreted the cause of
those catastrophes but nonetheless
when you look at the criticisms you've
heard of emmanuel velikovsky right
velikov's thing i've heard it from you
okay well he was
famous best-selling author one of the
big best-selling authors of the 1950s
you know maybe in a sense a forerunner
of in fact graham
hancock has been compared to velikovsky
now and then i've
actually seen some of some of that
although velikovsky's work i don't think
was anywhere near as credible as
graham's
um graham is very uh very assiduous in
his
his referencing and his detailing and so
velikovsky went way off into this really
weird astrophysics to explain
his his theories of geological
catastrophe
which again allowed the critics to
basically dismiss everything he had done
so his but his book earth and upheaval i
think has upheld the test of time or
basically in the 1950s he was
accumulating all of this evidence
suggesting that um
there had been catastrophes in earth
history and was
like i said a bestseller but the
mainstream scientific community was very
dismissive of it okay and then
after that you had um a book called uh
uh by charles hapgood called the path of
the poll
i think it came out in 76. and he he and
there theorized that there had been a
sudden pole shift that had brought about
you know the
quick freezing of the mammoths and the
end of the ice age and so forth
um so you know i was familiar with that
stuff and i would i would read that
stuff
just out of curiosity you know um
because that was
some of the stuff that was out there and
and um you know somebody would say hey
did you read
velikovsky and so as i was reading this
stuff i would keep thinking back to this
image i'd had of this you know and then
in the early 80s i was talking to
somebody i actually gave one of my very
early lectures on this stuff and there
was a
somebody had a degree in geology who
stood up and he said
no no no that that valley that you're
talking about was created over millions
of years
i said i don't think so and we kind of
got into it a little bit and
but what that did was it kind of pissed
me off and i said okay i'm going to
research this thoroughly
and i did i thoroughly researched it i
went and i found
every single thing that had been written
on it and discovered that there's
actually mainstream geologists that have
said yeah
that river channel that giant river
channel was
actually created by a huge melt water
flood and they estimated that it's
volume they called it river warren
they estimated it as volume might have
been four thousand times greater
than the modern minnesota river that's
flowing in there so i felt very
vindicated from that and this was by the
early 80s
um so that was like one of the key
things there was other things you know i
am i spent the summer of 1970 mostly
sitting on a mountaintop in colorado
you know in a hut that i had built um
studying and reading stuff and
and traveling i you know this was back
in the days when you could
hitchhike and travel all over and i
think at one point i was with a buddy
and we were in his old
camper van and other times i was
hitchhiking but i spent the whole summer
traveling around the western states
and the thing i came away from that
summer with the you know i traveled the
first time i'd
traveled down to columbia gorge and as i
did i had this overwhelming sense
that there was something in the
landscape that i was that was
that was waiting to be revealed you know
i would look at these features
in the columbia gorge when i showed you
that huge that that waterfall with the
basalt over
that's in the columbia gorge so that was
the area i had traveled through in 1970
and i came away with that with this
sense that boy there's something
that that landscape is trying to tell me
and so
it goes back to that and i just you know
i got very interested in this stuff
um because i'm interested a in science
and i love the outdoors
so you know i love a good mystery you
know and i love
you know ancient traditions where sahala
sort of came together
over a period of you know a couple of
decades um
so i began really i would say
obsessively
really going into this um in the early
80s
you know where it went from just more or
less casual reading
into you know spending hours
in university libraries fi digging up
these things going back to the nine
going back like to the early geologists
to see what were they saying why did
they believe
that the history of the earth had been
catastrophic you know and um
and it just accelerated it doesn't seem
like
a ridiculous idea at all when you
consider what we see on the moon
the moon is so fascinating because we
can look right at it
there's no oceans there's no forests we
can see the evidence of impacts
all over it just completely covered
completely covered
with our minds living in this very small
window of
life you know if we're lucky we get a
hundred years and then of course you
know we have the history which goes back
to about seven
plus thousand years yeah just not enough
to really
to represent what we're looking at when
we look at the moon
we look at the moon this covered with
craters we're looking at potentially
billions of years of impacts yes and and
the assumption that those impacts ceased
hundreds of millions or billions of
years ago is clearly not correct well
there's no evidence that seized or why
it would cease
when we look at how many known
near-earth objects are floating around
oh in the last few years there's been
dozens of close flybys
there was one the other day that had a
[ __ ] moon yes
yes so something that flew by that had
its own moon yeah yeah that's wild
and and so think about this joe here's
what's happening
we've got geologists who are looking at
the crust of the earth
and discovering that yeah if we strip
away the biosphere and the oceans and
and account for plate tectonics the
earth is going to look like the moon
wow right there are now hundreds of
identified craters
right at the same time astronomers are
looking out into the near
space near earth neighborhood of space
and discovering
wait a second we assumed that you know
we were pretty much isolated that there
was nothing else going on we're now
realizing that near earth space is
densely populated the inner solar system
is densely
populated with cosmic debris
and this stuff is whizzing by us all the
time and it's
and now at the same time you've got
paleontologists
who are looking at the record of life
and realizing
that the record of life is not a smooth
curve
it's see-sawed you know life
proliferates and then suddenly
bam it's like the hammer comes down and
you have these mass extinction events
so this is our time right now but it
could very easily
end and there could be some new bug-like
creature that takes over
and becomes super smart a billion years
from now to me it all comes down to this
this to me is like okay
human species on planet earth it's time
for you to grow up and start paying
attention to the bigger picture because
whether you like it or not
you're a part of the bigger picture and
if we if we finally accept the fact that
maybe our predecessors have undergone
in a sense cultural mass extinctions you
know it suddenly
implies that we can't take our own
unending future for granted that we have
to we have to incorporate this bigger
picture into our thinking
and um you know the evidence is
continues to um
yes like here this was just from 2011
multiple lines of evidence for possible
human population decline
settlement reorganization during the
early younger driest
in the three years four years since this
was published more
evidence has emerged that yes the
the events that caused the mass
extinction of half the great mega
mammals on earth
did not leave the rest of the mammals
the rest of the animals unscathed
including humans
and there's now emerging evidence hard
scientific evidence that the human
population crashed
during the younger dryas so this would
completely
coincide with graham hancock's ideas
about the sphinx
the sphinx absolutely showing very clear
according to robert shock boston
university
geologist john anthony john anthony west
that there is
clear evidence of water erosion on the
sphinx which would indicate
thousands of years of rainfall where
there hasn't been rainfall in the nile
valley since like i believe it was 9000
bc
yeah so that's 11 000 years ago it's all
the same stuff
it's all the same stuff god this is
crazy
yeah we're we're on the verge of a
major paradigm shift and and
where it's going to go remains to be
seen we live in a shooting gallery
we live we listen it's not an
exaggeration to say that we
are sitting ducks in a cosmic shooting
gallery exactly
but the point is here's the point is
the only thing that's see it's like what
was it in the in the book of matthew
there's an interesting quote and i'm not
you know i'm not not thumping the bible
here but the bible is full of just like
all the traditions
of ages are gone the bible is full of
some very powerful interesting stuff
there's a part in here where one of the
disciples asked jesus about
when are we going to know about the end
of days
and he says well as it was in the days
of noah
when the people were eating and drinking
and marrying and giving in marriage
so will it be again in the days the end
of days
when the flood comes when the people
were eating and drinking marrying and
giving in marriage until the flood came
and swept them away
so will it be again at the end of days
so
what that seems to indicate to me is
that we just get
comfortable and relaxed and do well yeah
and when we do well that's when we get
hip better
it's it's not saying that the everyday
stuff the the stuff of everyday life
there's anything wrong it's not saying
that it's just saying
if we get so preoccupied with the
minutiae and the trivia of
everyday life to the exclusion of the
bigger picture
that's when we open ourselves up well
there's been i've had these weird
conversations with people about
me asteroidal impacts over the years
because i've before i even met you
i've been obsessed with this stuff not
nearly as much as when i met you in
atlanta and we started talking then i
got really into it
but what they would talk about the the
asteroids that killed the dinosaur oh
today we'd be able to stop that
and i'm like okay really is that true
and then i started looking into it well
what has been done is there's
nothing some [ __ ] theories see here
here's the thing
potentially yes we could someday we
could do it and really
you know within within a decade or two
yes we could we could do that
right now potentially but see what
happened on february 15th of 2014 when
that
little meteor came in and exploded over
chelyabinsk siberia
injured 1500 people now
you know and damaged thousands of
buildings that was a wake-up call
right that was a little speck that was a
little speck
now here's the thing if it had been a
little bigger
a little denser if it's an angle of
approach had been a little steeper
if its velocity had been a little bit
greater we might have been looking at
thousands of
of deaths rather than just injuries and
tunguska as you said
only a hundred and fifty foot wide only
150 foot wide object right
right so that's very very small in the
cosmic
room yeah well it's the building yeah
well from here to the front door
yeah you know i mean that's not that big
that's not that big what you've got
though is velocity
and you think like you know think of a
say a 38 slug
it's not big if i was to throw it at you
even as hard as i could it might sting a
little bit but it wouldn't do any damage
but if it came out of a gun with a
muzzle velocity of a thousand feet per
second think about that little thing and
what the damage it would do to you
yeah and see that's the thing about an
asteroid or a meteorite or a comet
coming in it's moving really really fast
you know so uh that's why like i said it
packs such a powerful kinetic punch
when it hits and some of them are even
made of iron
some of them are made of iron
so so if there's if there's a moral to
all of this
it's simply this look we are the one
species
that could prevent the type of mass
extinctions that have dominated the
biosphere of this planet for a couple of
hundred million years
or we could keep putting our resources
to fracking
yeah well i still haven't made up my
mind about fracking yet but you know i
do believe
that what we need to do is be thinking
of
if we're going to extract the resources
of this planet
let's do so in such a way that what
we're doing is
implementing the transcendence of human
culture
into the cosmos itself because i
ultimately believe that
is the destiny of terrestrial life is
that terrestrial life
wants to become cosmic it knows on some
level
that as long as life is confined to the
surface of a planet it's vulnerable
right and and you know it's without
getting into all of this there's
there's growing evidence you know that
life originally came to this planet from
space
right was seeded here probably through
comets
that carry organic material all the
spare panspermia exactly
um so here's the thing
you know if you're an environmentalist
and rightfully critical of some of the
things that humans are doing to to
to disrupt the environment you gotta
though place in context the fact that
nature itself
has done things to the environment so
that so far exceed anything we have done
yet
what i showed you with that slide
showing the ice sheets over
canada think about this suppose some
logging company got a contract from the
government
u.s and canadian governments to
clear-cut
every forest from like the 47th parallel
up to the arctic circle from the
atlantic to the pacific we're going to
cut
every single tree from the northern
united states up to
the tree line in in northern canada
we're going to cut
billions of trees billions of board feet
we're going to clear cut
every single tree we would rightfully be
up in arms and say no you're not going
to do that
right well what do you think that ice
did
it wiped out you know there's evidence
now that 35 and 40 000 years ago there
were forests growing up there
right a few thousand years later the ice
has bulldozed everything there's no
forests growing under two miles of ice
right imagine if we said well we're
going to just
decimate the shallow marine ecologies
we're going to go in there and we're
going to just wipe out the coral reefs
we're going to overfish until there's no
nothing nothing left of the shallow
marine college ecologies
less than 400 feet you know below sea
level
well what do you think a drop in 400
feet of 400 feet in the sea level did
to the shallow marine ecologies to the
coral reefs that we're growing there
you see that's what i'm just saying it's
not to justify
that we can ransack nature willy-nilly
but it's to say we have to have a
realistic context for thinking about
this
and bear in mind the the environmental
movement
was born during an era of total
gradualistic dominance in the 50s and
60s if you go back then
again only the fringe the the the you
know this
the the fringe sciences people like
velikovsky and others
were talking about catastrophes the
assumption was is that all global change
occurred one grain of sand or
one drop of water at a time right well
we've come 180 degrees from that model
of earth history
but our thinking has not really evolved
to
to to incorporate such a dynamic planet
you know at this point now see so when
the environmental movement was born it
was easy to think that
if if all change had happened at this
imperceptibly slow rate
yeah obviously then humans have
accelerated that pace of change and
humans are now contributing
to you know more global change than than
we've seen in millions of years
if that uniformitarian or gradualistic
model was correct
but it's not and i'm afraid that there's
a large faction of the environmental
movement that's still
locked into that thinking of a
gradual evolution of the planet one
grain of water
one drop of water one grain of sand at a
time and it has not suffered
any kind of disruption until we bad
humans came along
and started you know with our factories
and our oil wells and
our suvs and everything else
but you know clearly we have to come to
terms with the fact that we live on one
hell of a dynamic planet
and one hell of a dynamic solar system
one hell of a diamond without jupiter
right we'd be
[ __ ] a long time we would be somebody
said they wanted to hear me say the word
[ __ ] at least
once um
so i'll throw i'll go ahead and throw it
yeah we would be [ __ ] jupiter is the
big kind
like the the bouncer for all the the
bigger asteroids it gets sucked in
well jupiter can play a dual role see
jupiter can act as a as yeah the bouncer
that that kicks
a lot of those guys back out you know
back out into the kuiper disk or
wherever they came from or from
but it can also hurtle stuff in
towards us it can do either one sacred
geometry is a subject that i wanted to
talk to you about
because we we could go on about
cataclysmic
impacts forever but it's one of the
things that you mentioned at the end of
our last podcast that you wanted to talk
about on this one
yeah um and it's the name of your
organization sacred geometry well it's
the name of the website
um yeah i could find some stuff here to
show you about that and
it dovetails because remember we're
talking here a lot about
geology geometry right they both
are sciences that have evolved out of
the study of the earth
and uh you know one of the things that
i've done
is is you know in geology we have this
thing called scale and variance
which is that if you look at a
geological picture you're always going
to see
somebody you're going to see like a rock
pick set in the picture
you're going to see a person standing
there because oftentimes
you don't have a sense of the scale of
what you're looking at right if
and in geometry we have the same
phenomena it's also kind of the modern
term for it is fractalization
where the part looks the the smaller
part looks like the bigger hole and
that's one of the basic
working ideas of sacred geometry and
it's the same idea of what i was
describing
standing there looking into the
minnesota river valley
this was an example of scale in variance
that
you had the same that the big channel
was just a much much
larger version of this small channel and
that if you didn't have a scale of
reference
you couldn't tell really what you're
looking at how how big or how small it
is see
so in the study of sacred geometry one
of the fundamental ideas is this idea of
scale and variance so
when i first was interested in geometry
because
geometry i think is one of the keys to
deciphering many of the ancient
traditions like
you know i became a somebody wanted me
to talk about freemasonry and i
you know can talk about that up to a
certain extent you know i
you know one of the things that that i
learned as soon as
actually i think i learned it before i
was actually initiated into the masonic
fraternity in 1978
was that at the core of all the masonic
symbolism was geometry
if you wanted to understand the message
of the great cathedrals
you had to have geometry if you wanted
to understand
the the the this amazing plethora of
symbolism
that is of which masons are the
custodians
you had to study geometry and
secondarily you had to study astronomy
so that sort of confirmed some of the
ideas i had already been thinking at the
time that i went in
in the late 70s freemasonry is
full of symbolism why did you join the
freemasons
well you know because for one thing i've
always loved our you know i come from a
family of builders
i build things for a living that's what
i do i design things
and i build things for a living that's
what i how i make my money
so i was always interested in the built
environment
and somewhere along the line i just
began to realize that there was a whole
lot more to the built environment of
ancient times
that in modern times you look at
architecture
and that architecture is not necessarily
symbolical
except on a very abstract sense i became
aware of the fact that the ancient
architecture the ancient structures
whether it's the pyramids of giza or
stonehenge or angkor wat or the mayan
temples
they're all profoundly symbolic
they're not just built because hey it
looks good
no it's they convey information
um you know cathedrals it was victor
hugo who referred to some of the great
cathedrals as being
literal textbooks in stone and that's
what they are
shark cathedral beautiful example of a
textbook in stone
and and uh i have i don't know if you've
ever been
to any of the cathedrals no that's
something you need to put on your bucket
list joe
yeah i'm planning on going to europe
this summer so when i do
uh on a vacation instead of working yeah
that's
yeah make it a research vacation it'll
make it a lot more interesting and
before you go
have kids it's tough to do a lot of
research we've got little kids that get
bored real easy but i'm gonna check some
[ __ ] out yeah check check some [ __ ] out
you know
i can send you some places that that i
don't know about your kids but i could
easily have been eight years old and
been totally blown away by
okay you know well one of the things
about
the freemasons the idea of the
freemasons is
that it's a secret society yeah and
there's a secret you know and people
associate it with the illuminati and the
people that control the world
and don't i wish but
you know joe i think i would love to be
the dick dick supreme dictator of the
world
really what would you do differently uh
differently
we could get in that's going to be yeah
that's a five-hour budget yeah that's a
different podcast
right um the but
when you say like uh i'm a mason people
would automatically
you know especially ignorant people
would automatically assume that you're a
part of some sort of society
that's victimizing the general
population and you're
involved with the people that put the
eyeball on top of the pyramid that's on
the dollar bill
and you're you know i don't even know
where to start with some of that
are there secrets in the freemasons were
you not allowed to talk about it
well bear in mind now secrets
you know in in the middle ages there
were trade secrets
and you know uh building secrets clearly
you know
um and when you went through the process
of initiation you learned about these
secrets
right but it's it's not that really that
different the idea than say modern
uh you know uh commercial or industrial
secrets
you know coke has it keeps it formula
secret
right right and it's done so for a
hundred years right
but the thing was is you got to realize
that freemasonry became an outlawed
organization
right during the middle ages when the
church was persecuting
anybody who was branded a heretic which
could have meant
anything that they wanted to be
freemasonry had to go underground
and that's the primary reason for the
secrecy
um is because it was a survival strategy
and it only re-emerged in the early
1700s with the consolidation
of four lodges in britain to become the
modern institution freemason
and you know to anybody who comes up
with that i would just challenge them
show me the hard evidence show me that
you know
i like to say that well yeah i'll admit
you know 14 of the american presidents
have been freemasons but 22 of them were
episcopalians
so clearly that implies to me that it's
the episcopalians who are the puppet
masters ruling the world
right if you want to make that argument
well why
were they freemasons like what's the
benefits of being a freemason
well for one thing what you're doing is
you're aligning yourself
with probably the oldest institution
that still exists on the planet
that goes back now we can historically
trace it back to the middle ages
but if you go back further than that
while the historical continuity
breaks down we can go back and we can
talk about the coma chains in italy we
can talk about the martinis
we can talk about the um the mithraeus
tradition we can talk about the
mysteries of egypt
uh we can talk about the the zoroastrian
tradition
um the list goes on the elusinian
mysteries and what we see
is a structure of initiation that's
virtually identical in all these cases
to what modern freemasonry is
and um with modern freemasonry basically
you know you have a whole cross-section
of individuals that join who
who a lot of them join simply because
hey my dad was a freemason or my uncle
it was a family tradition
so that's why i joined others joined
because freemasons raised every year
raised
millions of dollars for charity mostly
for children's charitable causes you
know they run the
uh scottish right hospital for crippled
and burned children they run eye
hospitals and
you know children that need medical care
they can go to these hospitals
and not have to pay anything so their
their fraternal organization they're one
of the largest charitable organizations
on the planet in terms of the money that
they raise
you know again jesus said you by their
by their works ye shall know them
you know um you know you can
twist that around perversely twist that
around and say that's some kind of
nefarious strategy to
you know whatever get control the other
side of the equation is that they're
also custodians
of this body of ancient symbolism where
all of these things that we have been
talking about uh
basically are encoded um and
and i could pull up some interesting
stuff here that you you know that you
could
could look at to see um what we're
actually talking about there but
but yeah they have this amazing body of
symbolism let me let me pull it here's
an example of a masonic
apron okay let's take a look at this
we'll zoom in here
and what do you see right at the very
center of this
symbol symbolical array what do you what
is that
i think it's a barn it's not a bar it's
not the ark it's the ark
it's you know it's probably it's noah's
ark because noah's ark so that's the
so that's supposed to be the ocean
around it it's floating in the waters of
the great flood
and and if you look closely i know it's
hard to tell but growing out of here
it's a chicken no it's an acacia
the occasion it's a masonic symbol for
rebirth regeneration rejuvenation so the
idea here is that in that
arc has preserved all of the seeds the
biological diversity of the world that
is now being erased from the planet by
the waters of the flood
the acacia is it related to the acacia
tree or the acacia bush is it the same
sort of thing yeah
you know that's the same bush that they
believe is responsible for moses having
the visions
of god so what are giving him the ten
commandments because the acacia
bush is rich in dimethyltryptamine ah
the flaming bush this being symbolic of
somehow another extracting the dmt from
that
smoking it or lighting it on fire and
that being the transmission method for
the dimethyltryptamine which of course
is one of the most profound psychedelic
experiences
and gives people this feeling of being
in contact with the divine
now do you think it's any coincidence
that the freemasons have
venerated the acacia for hundreds of
years it makes a lot of sense it makes a
lot of sense doesn't it yeah
yeah well there's modern-day scholars
who are looking at this
the story of moses and connecting it to
some sort of a psychedelic trip
yeah here is which is another thing
that's slowly
being exonerated today those ideas are
being vindicated today
yeah that before you know you would say
just a few decades ago that somehow or
another moses was on drugs
like get the [ __ ] out of here yeah and
people would just and any
real legitimate sort of uh stories being
connected to psychedelic drugs people
would think of as being preposterous and
now
it's more and more accepted every day
right simply because
the evidence is accumulation it's
overwhelming the election there's no
question that in the alessinian
mysteries they were imbibing some type
of a consciousness altering
substance i think that there's no
question during the mithraic mysteries
also they were they don't know what that
was though right
not exactly unless you you know i think
um who was it maybe albert hoffman and a
couple others
they they wrote a book in the 70s on the
yellowstone mysteries where they were
talking about that and i read it so long
ago i've kind of forgotten
what their what their final conclusion
was but it was definitely that they were
doing some type of a psychedelic potion
believe in
soma when you go back to yeah the
ancient hindus the soma being
some sort of a mystery concoction they
don't know what it was but
most likely had some sort of psychedelic
properties too because they don't know
what it was
they don't know exactly what it was this
is amazing when you consider the fact
that
this stuff was so profound so important
to them
and now we don't even know what was in
it most likely some concoction with
probably included psychedelic mushrooms
yeah
well i'm convinced that you know one of
the that one of the great boons to
humankind is
psychedelics and it was a profound
mistake to criminalize it when we should
have venerated it as ancient cultures
did and provided a
context in which people could do it with
wisdom
you know and propriety rather than
driving it underground you know turning
it into a
criminal enterprise that has been i
think enormously had enormous
destructive consequences for our society
by by criminalizing this for the last
half century
yeah well most certainly and you can see
the difference in the art of the 1960s
especially when
it comes to music the difference between
the 60s and the 70s
the shallow nature of a lot of the music
that came out of the 70s and the disco
and all that stuff
and then look at what was going on the
60s with hendricks and yeah jim morrison
most likely psychedelic related oh of
course it was
yeah yeah of course led zeppelin the
beatles yeah the profound change in the
music of the beatles once they
discovered the lsd
oh it inspired an enormous burst of
creativity
what's really interesting that what
we're seeing now is huge benefits in
psychedelic therapy for people with
post-traumatic stress disorder right
and it's out of war that we're finding
these
therapies for people that went to war
and these therapies the best ones
are psychedelics yeah which is really
amazing well you know in my own case you
know i basically went from
essentially being a juvenile delinquent
to the quest for god in one weekend
after my first
basically so wow
it was that that quick a lot of people
have had the same story i mean
terence mckenna spoke of his uh one of
his trips to the jungle
being that he was this sort of narrative
well just couldn't get it together
and then he came out of it the
psychedelic shaman who had this intense
desire to spread the word
yeah yeah yep so
yeah and i think it's we're definitely
moving in the right direction i just
it's of course you know
for me i'm impatient i want to see it
move a lot faster i want to see us just
end this ridiculous drug war yeah you
know and and yeah of course there's
going to be a downside to it there's
downside to everything you know and but
the upside is so substantive the upside
is so substantial and the downside of it
is minuscule compared to the downside of
the drug war itself
not only that how about the drugs that
we already have that are legal that
those drugs that are sanctioned are the
worst ones worse ones yeah
we're not going to have a drug free
society i've had dr carl hart
on the podcast who's an expert in this
has written
some uh pretty uh amazing stuff on it
and one of the things that he said is
not only do we not
want a drug free culture we've never had
one
right no one has ever had this idea of a
drug free culture they've never existed
right once people figured out a way to
perturb their normal states of
consciousness and the benefits of that
whether it's alcohol
or psychedelics or whatever it's been
even yoga and meditation you're
essentially
you're you're stimulating endogenous
drugs yes
yes and and see here's the thing it's
somebody brought this up i don't
remember who it might have been somebody
like richard albert or something back in
the day
saying that you know you can go you can
embark on a quest
for spiritual enlightenment and mystical
at one minute right
through through this arduous program of
of yoga and meditation and
and all of that and it'll take you years
but
who is going to embark upon such a
program not really knowing
that the end of it is this ecstatic
mystical union with
the godhead right well they said that
basically
nature's provided shortcuts so that you
know we could actually see
what the goal of it was and know that
yeah at the end of this
process that might take you 10 years or
five years or whatever
depending on your dedication there is
this
all this experience of your
consciousness expanding
into these ecstatic states agents of
evolution as it were and
that's the thing that people i think
universally
feel from psychedelic experiences is
that it allows you to get over
a lot of these sort of built-in
instincts that we have from our
thousands of years of evolution
and the the time that we're essentially
living
like wild animals i mean those those
genes
are still in our system and we have all
these
ideas of paranoia and fear
and ego and the you know jealousy and
all these different things that allowed
us
to be ultra competitive which allowed us
to innovate at a faster rate which
allowed us to get to where we are in
2015 but those things are kind of
hampering us
yeah because we're outgrowing the monkey
body
it's like you know if we're gonna travel
to um
we want to travel to europe right you
can't drive there in a car you can go
drive from here to the east coast but
once you get to the coastline you have
to get out of the car and get into a
different vehicle
right because if you keep driving in the
same car you're gonna go into the ocean
and you're gonna drown
right we're kind of like that in the
sense that you know
see i think that war was perhaps
inevitable
you know this this because it's em
embedded in our consciousness you see
i just showed you here evidence that the
human population crashed
coming out of the younger dryas well
what's ironic is that
after the after the ice age was over for
about three or four thousand years from
six thousand to about nine thousand
nine thousand five hundred years ago
what we had was a period
known as the climatic optimum by the
scientists who've looked at it
in which some of the estimates are that
global average climate might have been
two to four degrees warmer than now
what that meant was that you had a much
longer growing season and
anybody who doubts this please do your
own research or i can post
all kinds of stuff online that anybody
who's not immediately
you know you know
can't handle this this can kind of
information anybody who's open-minded
can actually go and do their homework
and see that the
the climate climatic optimum is well
documented
and for about three to four thousand
years
basically we were living in an almost
quasi-paradisial state
almost a garden of eden like it was
almost like after the traumatic
birth of this modern age the holocene
that we're in
it's like nature just sort of was this
nurturing environment it was during this
period
that humans were worshiping the earth in
the form of this
corpulent pregnant goddess right it's
been called the goddess civilization by
maria gimboutus who was the
archaeologist who did all of this work
and what was interesting if you look
into her work is that during this period
of the
of the early neolithic in the
archaeological terminology
there's no evidence that of any warfare
there's no evidence that people
you know looking at at the the carvings
that people did the the the artwork that
people did
looking at the communities there were
not stockades like there were later
there was no evidence um in the in the
archaeological record of you know
weaponization
and it makes sense because in the
aftermath
of this extreme event that ended the ice
age what you had was
huge areas of the planet that were
depopulated
nature quickly begins to reclaim um
and what you now have is you have this
sort of this benign
warmth where growing seasons are
months longer than now you know farming
you know 14 1500 feet higher in the
mountains than is now
possible um you know uh
you know long longer growing seasons and
rapid expansion of population during
this this era
this would have been the era you know
think think about what was the biblical
injunction that yahweh gave to adam and
eve what did he say
be fruitful and multiply replenish the
earth
and subdue it be fruitful and multiply
well if
you've got a species hovering on the
brink of extinction what's the most
important thing that that species can do
lots of sex lots of reproduction right
in the context of those times it would
have been very important for people to
have
lots of sex to quickly re-establish the
viability of the human species because
we were literally
it now appears hovering on the brink of
extinction as were
so many of the other large mammals of
the planet right
and nature gave us this interval this
window of three or four thousand years
of extremely
mild climate right during this time
human population rapidly expanded and
moved into these vacated habitats
around six thousand years ago the
climate shifted
what started was has been called by the
paleoclimatologist the neo-glaciation
because the planet cooled a couple of
degrees
what happened agricultural habitats
contracted the the growing the the
the elevation of viable agriculture came
down
okay now if you've got settled human
communities that have become well
established
and living in the context of that
environment
and now suddenly that environment
changes right
exactly coincident with those
environmental changes around 6000 years
ago is when we see
the first appearance of human conflict
because now with this change in climate
you've got this disruption this major
disruption in human communities that
have been
well established and proliferating for
three or four thousand years
think about you know if you're you know
living in a in a community and you're
farming at 10 000 feet above sea level
a smaller example a micro example would
be the freezing out of the of the
greenland colonists
with the onset of the little ice age
right
for 500 years they were able to farm on
the west coast of greenland
and then the little ice age came on and
they were frozen out
and they tried to hang on as long as
they could but it kept getting harder
and harder to grow crops
and then the climate declined further
and the sea ice began to move
south and the one they who waited too
long
lost their opportunity because once the
sea ice had moved south it cut off the
sea lanes
so that they could actually evacuate the
greenland colonies completely went
extinct
iceland itself was almost completely
depopulated during this
if we take that scenario expand it and
go back 6000 years ago
we essentially see a very similar
parallel phenomena going on
and so when you figure for during that a
civilization
age of the goddess this this time that
people were worshiping the earth in the
form of this corpulent
pregnant goddess this benign motherly
nurturing goddess
there was no reason for conflict because
human populations were small they were
isolated
resource base was enormous and then
with the climate change what happened
suddenly now
human communities and populations are
disrupted
migrations began happening one group
conflicts with another group
and now we see the implements and the
evidence of warfare
if we go back to ten thousand twelve
thousand years ago
clearly whatever happened then must have
been profoundly traumatic to the
survivors
think about this if you were the
survivor of an event
that basically erased modern
civilization and you were living in a
small
isolated band of survivors with no way
to communicate with the rest of the
world
and no knowledge of whether there was
even other survivors anywhere on the
earth
it could profoundly affect you your your
consciousness
and and that could be so profound that
it's
the imprint of those events could be so
profound that it could be
passed on you know for generations
and and be lodged in our subconscious
this idea of human conflict necessary
for human survival and the traumas that
have been visited upon our species by
nature itself
so i think that once we come to terms
with the
possibly origins of huma only until we
come to terms with the origin of human
conflict
are we going to be able to purge it once
and for all
and and realize that that the modern
analog for that scenario was that
coming out of that catastrophe abundant
resources
abundance habitat abundant space
no conflict for territory resources
because the human population was
limited what i suggest is that if people
want to understand
the viable future of the human species
go out on a
crystal clear night and look at the sky
there is the future there's our
potential future because
the scenarios that have been around
since the 1970s show
that everything that we're extracting
now from the earth
the minerals the precious metals the
hydrocarbons
it's all out there in infinite abundance
and it's basically
just outside of our doorstep and we are
as close
now to being able to harvest the
resources of the cosmic environment
as we were from setting foot on the moon
in 1960.
do you think we've been visited before
by something from other planets
i think perhaps long long ago maybe but
there's another scenario there that
has been overlooked in all of the
discussions about ufos and aliens and at
some point we'll talk about that
at some point yeah you tease
well you know it's the kind of thing
where you kind of need to
lay out the case and and what i like to
do
is basically present the evidence and
see if
whoever then draws the same conclusions
from that evidence that i have
so okay let me let me put it to you this
way
in what we were talking about at the
very beginning of this interview
and and talking about 7 000 generations
of people
and and the fact that in in four or five
generations we went from horseback to
rocket ships
how many times in the last 7 000 years
do you suppose
that we could have done that to me it's
not impossible that we could have
achieved
flight even inter in interplanetary
flight
more than once just as we have now just
think about it
we have we have achieved interplanetary
flight even though only manned
expeditions to to nearer space but we're
sending our
satellites out beyond the solar system
all of this has come about in my
lifetime
right totally in my lifetime all of it
since the 1950s my grandfather
when he was a kid you know it was horses
and a big point
is that if we died off now for some sort
of mass extinction event there'd be very
little evidence of this
space travel thousands there'd be no
evidence yet all the aluminum all the
the stuff that the rockets you got out
of it would all be gone
right the earth would absorb it now
let's just consider
as a wild outrageous working hypothesis
that humans have been able to offload
from the planet
prior to it prior to the modern space
age
so one point in time we went to mars
there's probably somewhere a little
closer than that it would have made
sense
like the moon like the moon like we've
been able to establish a base on the
moon
yeah now this isn't like i said i'm just
crazy right up front this is an
outrageous mason crazy you're a heretic
what else you've done drugs dismiss this
man
this this is over it's time to lock me
away
gag me muzzle me and laugh we consider
the fact that our civilization
you know if all your theories are true
which they most certainly appear to be
our civilization has been rebooted as of
12 000 years ago
modern civilization emerges somewhere
around 7 000 years ago
in 4.6 billion years of life on earth or
excuse me of the life of the earth the
earth existing and then life on earth
being
you know in our form what few hundred
thousand years
right in a hundred thousand years is a
long time that's
ten ten events since the big
impact ten times well remember the
greenland ice core graph that i showed
you i mean
what you're seeing there is a dozen or
more
enormous events in the last quarter
million years
in the time probably the huma again the
oldest human skeleton
modern modern human skeleton is now
dated to about 180 000 years
how much earlier than that were we i
don't know but
conservatively we can say 180 000 years
that greenland ice core graph that i
showed you goes back 250
000. so the rigveda stories of the
vamanas and the flying
crafts and all that could actually have
been based on real
live objects real live spaceships
read the sumerian stories what did they
say in the wake of the flood it was so
disastrous that what did the gods do
they fled the earth and went to space it
says right there in the myth itself
says they left they went went they left
the earth and went to the heavens
because what was going on on the earth
was so traumatic it even freaked them
out
read the story the gods the gods anki
and eon
and nina ninerta and the rest of them
what did you think of zechariah sitchin
and his
fantastical translations of the sumerian
texts
i'm dubious about some of history most
are right yeah
most people who are experts in the
sumerian languages in cuny forum
yeah think that he was kind of cuckoo
kind of cuckoo yeah well but
what's fascinating is there's so much
that they absolutely
understood that's really confusing like
they understood
they had an accurate depiction of our
solar system which included
pluto which included all the planets
in all the orbit in in in the correct
you know relatively correct sizes on
these clay tablets
that they made nine thousand seven
thousand who knows how many thousand
years ago
you know yeah i i guess i'm you know i
read some sitchin stuff
years and years ago and at the time took
it with a grain of salt
and subsequent to that you know after
i've seen some of the the critiques of
him
you know i'm kind of in that category
myself of thinking his is
you know his some of his translations
are are dubious he made some leaps
for sure but what they did discover what
they have this
just it's so fascinating to me when you
look at like the caduceus
which will very clearly resembles the
double helix of dna
and how it's closely associated with
some of these images of
larger beings holding little smaller
people
with tails like what the [ __ ] is that
like this idea of genetic engineering of
taking lower primates and introducing
human or alien dna into these lower
primates to create modern humans
i don't know what to think about that it
sounds ridiculous
but if we found a planet like let's say
we exist
in this state right now and uh we
uh we evolve without getting hit in the
head by a big rock from space
for another thousand years or another 10
000 years let's
get really [ __ ] crazy just imagine
how far we could come if we don't blow
ourselves up
we don't yellowstone doesn't explode we
live another
10 000 years and we jet off into the
cosmos and find some planet with a bunch
of dumb monkeys on it
you don't think we would splice our dna
into those dumb monkeys just to say
listen i think you guys could do better
you could be like us we're going to give
you a little bump we know what's coming
if you guys keep going along this way
you could get to where we are
in the million plus years we can get a
little injection maybe it's in how about
a scenario like this okay
well from our superior perspective we
know that you guys down there are living
on a vulnerable planet that's going to
be
have its ass kicked every so often right
so we're going to do something to
accelerate your evolution a bit
so that perhaps you can uh become a
little bit more intelligent and figure
this out
we're going to leave some clues behind
for you and
you know then we're going to leave it in
your hands to basically redeem to redeem
the planet
it's amazing how often people just like
will completely dismiss any ideas like
that but yet
we clearly are we're very advanced and
compared to life on earth
but clearly we're advancing
into the solar system at the very least
with robots
you know we haven't really been doing
manned space trips anymore but we're
sending a lot of [ __ ] robots
yeah we're sending satellites we're
sending all these things to
go around other planets and take images
we're
sending robots that land on mars to rove
around
and take photos and soil samples and
send
information back through the sky to
earth i mean that's pretty
it is fantastic stuff well imagine
if you tried to describe to this this to
somebody 100 years ago
they'd go get out of here yeah this is
outrageous i don't even want to hear
such
ridiculous times but like you just said
considering the pace of change over the
last century
you know given us a century ago there
was no airline industry right
of course the thing was if you know if
you had the you know
government bureaucracies like you like
you have now back then
orville and wilbur would have never been
able to test their flights because some
government bureaucrat
would have been out there saying you
don't have the proper permits to do this
right
and right now that's i you know one of
the big obstacles is that we've gotten
we've got these top heavy political
systems that are really i think
really encumbering the creative process
the evolutionary process that's why i'm
such a big supporter of of basically
freedom
you know getting back to the idea of
individual liberty
because i think the upside of people
being free
yeah of course there's a cost of freedom
and there's going to be a downside to it
but
the upside i think again is so much
greater than the downside that
that's what the internet is showing the
internet is it represents freedom the
free
the ability to freely distribute
information
this show itself would have never
existed this podcast
could not have existed without something
like the internet no one would have ever
given me a show
no one ever like said yeah go talk to
this guy from
georgia for three hours about asteroid
impacts people will like it
you know get out of here get the [ __ ]
out of here actually i'm from minnesota
well i mean you live there yeah you know
right but it's just
the whole idea is that freedom allows
people to innovate at a much quicker
pace yes
it allows negative things too but so
does life itself there's
there's more of a chance of negative
things
if things are controlled yeah if things
are
locked down and innovation goes where
does you know it goes right out i
mean in my own personal sphere like 20
years like i'm building a project right
now
in atlanta took me six months and nine
trips
down to city hall to get permission from
the bureaucrats to do a small project
which 20 years ago i could have gotten
that permission
in an hour or two 20 years before that i
didn't even
would have would not have even needed
permission from anybody
you know oh you've got your own house
you want to do this your neighbors don't
care
we'll do it see right so this is
what my experience there multiply that
by millions across the board you know
it's like
you know it's going to get to the point
where you know can we do we dare
breathe out without a permit because
we're exhaling carbon dioxide
you know right so um
yeah i just i think that a couple of
things need to happen one we need to
really
get back to the idea and america that's
the great dream and vision of america
was that this was supposed to be the
home of
freedom on planet earth yeah bureaucracy
is pretty disgusting but it's also i
feel like
sometimes we need some resistance in
order to facilitate action
some resistance yeah and some resistance
sometimes
gives us this real desire to overcome
that resistance which
makes innovation yeah you know and that
might be one of the things that we're
experiencing with this new culture
that's emerging from the internet
it's kind of emerging in response to the
resistance that we
received from i mean going back to
psychedelics from the 60s to the 70s
70s into the 80s and the 90s the
internet emerges
and the internet is causing this big
push back
on all the archaic ideas of being
promoted during those
dark decades yeah
and i totally agree with you i mean
without some resist i mean
after all i mean if there's no
resistance you know we're going to
basically turn into slugs
we turn into couch potatoes we turn the
couch delays right we're lazy
yeah it's very rare that human beings by
default
are ambitious it's like in response to
something like
one of the worst things you could do to
a kid is
give the kid everything they want and
not have them work
right they'd never develop any instincts
to work towards things they never
develop any
any instincts to to recognize that
there's a benefit to struggling and
being uncomfortable and that the rewards
when when you have a hard day's work and
a job completed that you feel satisfied
by
then the beer tastes so much better so
much better the jewish kabbalists have a
term for that which i can't remember but
it translates as the bread of shame
and it's like the bread of shame is the
bread you get that you didn't really
have to work for you didn't have to
struggle you didn't have to put forward
any effort it's just given to you you
know and
and you know it's like one of the the
the the stories that kind of goes along
with presenting that is
you know the the the the man who builds
up this great business empire you know
and then
um you know he's getting ready to retire
and he wants to pass it on to his son
and he says
you know come in i'm going to make you
ceo of my business empire and the whole
you're going to be able to run the whole
thing and the sun says no thanks i don't
want and he goes
what do you mean he says well let me
start at the bottom and work my way up
and earn
that position and it's going to mean a
whole lot more to me and i'm going to be
a hell of a lot more
effective in that position and if it's
just dumped in my lap
it's just so rare that anybody has that
mentality though most people would take
the easy road every single time
well and that is to the consternation i
think of our ancestors who didn't look
at it that way
you know the people that came across the
ocean you know at
great hardship didn't look at it that
way and i think that they would be
pretty much rolling in their graves if
they could see you know what's
basically oh well let's we'll just let
the government take care of us
right i don't have to get a job because
the government's going to take care of
us
but they would also look at our
computers and go holy [ __ ] you guys have
figured some things out
yeah wait a minute hold on you ask a
question to your phone and it gives you
the answer
yeah i mean they never even thought
about that on star trek
yeah and and see what that does is it
shows there's these parallel trends that
are that are happening you know so yeah
i'm i'm
you know i'm that's why i tend to be
more optimistic i'm not a pessimist i i
have great hopes for our future
i do too and people give me a hard time
for it sometimes you know they think i'm
unrealistic
or that that's the the hippie side of me
you know that i have a hippie ideology
as well um the sacred geometry
sacred geometry name like why did you
choose that as the name for your website
well because at the time i was looking
at there was so much interest
um and because i saw it as a a venue for
putting information out there about that
and showing some of the amazing
correlations and linkages
um you know between the subject of
geometry
and so many of these other things like i
said you know the mayan temples
egyptian structures and helping using
that
as a key to decipher or decode these
messages that have been
have been um embodied in architecture
it's the key it's the it's a master it's
one of the master keys to decoding
the archaic wisdom tradition there's no
question and geometry pervades
everything i mean geometry pervades
you know we can actually i can show you
now studies that have shown that the the
exact architecture of the solar system
if you changed it even a little bit
none of this could happen you know
because as it is now you have this
great reservoir of comets outside the
orbit of neptune called the kuiper disk
right
at the inside of that on the inner
perimeter of that disk of comets
uh comets are in a quasi-stable
condition
in other words it doesn't take much to
perturb them from that position
but at the same time there isn't much
there to perturb them so they generally
are just slowly orbiting the sun
well what happens is conjunctions of the
great outer planets
uranus and neptune primarily the
combined gravitational forces exerted on
the inner part of the kuiper disk are
enough to dislodge comets
and send them either either the gravity
effect think of this
if you've got a gravity effect pulling
on something from behind and it's moving
this way it's going to
act as a breaking mechanism if it's a
head
in drawing on it it's going to act as an
accelerating mechanism
so if you accelerate one of these
objects it moves out further from the
sun
if you decelerate it it moves in closer
to the sun
what happens is is that the conjunctions
of the outer planets
can move these comets inside the
the become within the sphere of
influence of the planets
and it just so happens in in
astrophysicists have worked out the
mathematics of it
that the masses and the spacing of the
four great outer planets jupiter saturn
uranus and neptune
are exactly what they need to be to
transport comets from the kuiper disk to
the inner solar system and if you change
that
even a little bit you would lose this
they've referred to it as the
the the uh the bucket mechanism or the
uh
uh like a bucket handoff each planet
will hand off
the comet to the next one and then when
it gets to jupiter the big one like you
said earlier jupiter is either going to
accelerate it and throw it back out
or it's going to decelerate it and send
it in towards the sun where it becomes
an earth crosser
where it begins to disaggregate and in
the process
fertilize the earth with its
constituents
which we now know are all kinds of
interesting and exotic materials
so if it turns out and it almost
certainly will and
in terms of the the panspermia idea that
that life was
originated on earth by comets that you
had to have an environment that was
conducive
you had to have this matrix of
environmental conditions that if were
altered slightly
would not allow the proliferation of
higher life you now have the
introduction of cometary material into
that
well if the architecture of the outer
solar system was not exactly lined up in
the geometry that it is
then you would never have that delivery
of the organics and the volatiles from
the comet
it's fact it's likely that the oceans
that the hydrosphere originated from
space
without the oceans where would life on
earth be you see
now here's where it gets interesting the
architecture of the solar system is
what's condensed
and embodied within the sacred
architecture of old
so they've taken that those proportions
however that got there
whether they knew it directly or on some
subconscious level
and incorporated that into the designs
and the proportions of the ancient
sacred structures
it's there basically the model of the
holy city the new jerusalem is described
in the
book of revelations is basically a model
of the solar system architecture
so it abides by bowed's law is that what
it is
yes i think it's bidet i think that's
how you say it
b-o-d-e-s is that what it was just
b-o-d-e b-o-d-e
oh it's boday yeah and i've only seen it
written um and it
that that law being that the size and
mass of a planet
allows you to extrapolate and find out
how
big and far away the next planet would
be
and so yeah it shows up that one of the
intervals within that sequence is
for example where the asteroid belt is
there's there's no planet there but
there's an asteroid
right and that sort of coincides with
the ancient sumerian myth of the
creation of earth being an
impact that there was a and also earth 1
and earth 2.
they've they know that earth was at one
point in time
different and it was impacted and that's
also what created the moon
right yes well that's that's the theory
about the moon but
got the moon i mean the moon is really
something we could talk about for the
next hour
and you know in it we can save that for
for a future
uh broadcast but the moon is really one
of the grand
symbols of the great mysteries with a
capital m no question um
and it's right there every night i mean
right now i think we're like one day
away from the full moon right now as
we're sitting here and
i would highly recommend that anybody
listening to this go out and begin
uh contemplating the moon unless you're
afraid of werewolves unless you're
afraid of werewolves
unless you're afraid of becoming
transformed into a werewolf
um yeah so the the how is jerusalem
designed in representation
as a representation of the solar system
uh well
the the uh the hypothetical jerusalem
the new jerusalem
well you know it describes this layout
um it gets complex um
and again when i show this to people i
usually rely on a lot of graphs and
images
and and reproductions uh geometric
diagrams and so on
but basically it's describing the city
lieth four square the length the height
and the breadth of it are equal twelve
thousand furlongs and there's a wall
great and high 144 cubits
according to the measure of a man that
is of the angel
and then it goes on to describe other
things but it's when you begin to
begin to do the analysis of these
numbers you discover
it it opens up this whole world of of
numerical symbolism
the twelve thousand furlongs you know
how much a furlong is
no furlong is one-eighth of a mile it
still exists it's a very ancient unit of
measurement still exists it's used in
horse racing that's the one place that i
know of it still exists
1 8 of a mile that's 660 feet right
now if you were to take the earth right
the earth you know is an oblate spheroid
it spins on its axis so it bulges
towards the equator
shrinks towards the polar axis so the
difference is about 7
900 miles at the polar axis about 7
926 miles at the equatorial axis
but if you were to take a perfect sphere
with the same
area surface area as the earth actually
has that sphere would be 7
920 miles in diameter now that number
729
7920 is a very interesting number
because for one thing if we look at a
furlong
a furlong is 660 feet so
i'm putting 660. once you take that
calculator okay
okay now that's a furlong 660 feet
convert that to inches by going times 12
times 12
times 12. one two okay and equals
equals seven nine
two zero there it is diameter of the
earth in miles
that i just said right right the the
perfect sphere
that would have the same surface area
and the same volume as the earth is 7920
miles that's
and that's actually the the diameter of
the earth if you took
a line from the tropic of cancer 23.5
degrees north
through the earth to the tropic of
capricorn you would discover that that
diameter is about 7
920 miles that's the number which i'm
theorizing and i'm thinking with a lot
of
evidence to back up that ancient peoples
used to symbolize the earth
7920 but what you've just seen here
is that this ancient unit of measurement
called the furlong which is 660 feet
is to the inch exactly as the earth
is to the mile now what was the origin
of the mile
what where did this mile we we brought
it up earlier
length of the mile 5280 feet
right what's the or think about the
latin word mill what does that mean
a thousand right like a million is a
thousand thousands
uh a a millimeter is one thousandth of a
meter
right because they're prefixing mil the
mill the latin
prefix that means a thousand right so in
the that's where the
actual word mile comes from so a mile
is a thousand what it's a thousand paces
human paces so if you were to go out and
walk off a thousand paces say counting
every time your right foot hit the
ground
and you did that a thousand times you're
gonna have a mile more or less depending
on
your size you know i'm six foot one so
i'm gonna have a slightly longer pace
than somebody who's five foot five right
but that's where the origin of the mile
comes from from five thousand uh
from a thousand paces and given that the
the
that's standardized but it's very
ancient see now
the outer circle of stonehenge the
sarson stone circle
if you were to encompass it in a circle
that just
tangent to the outer faces of the stone
the radius of that circle
is 50 has been has been measured and
it's almost exactly 52.8
feet right or one hundredth of a mile
now if you take the diameter of
stonehenge it's double that
which is 105.6 feet
right 50 times 100 point
105.6 there's your mile it suggests that
the mile was being used
by those who built stonehenge 5000 years
ago
but you see this number 5.28 is a
universal
relationship it it for one thing it says
the average human pace related to the
foot
which again remember protagoras said man
is the measure of all things
right where comes the inch it's this
here's the inch right here the origin of
the inch the distance between your thumb
yeah or it's or the width of your thumb
it's this well yeah so you can you can
measure here and that's going to be
an inch or you can take this and that's
an inch as well
so okay so it's the tip of your thumb to
the
the first joint yes that's essentially
nice and it depends because obviously
humans vary in size right right but the
idea here is that
the units of ancient measurement derive
from one of two sources
from the human yardstick or the earth
itself
okay so now if you take the average
human pace
divide it by the average human foot it's
5.28
multiply that by a thousand and you have
the mile of 5280 feet
right i'm suggesting that that
unit of measurement was actually
incorporated into the design
of stonehenge right now what we have
just seen
is that the description of the new
jerusalem in the book of revelations
describes it as being 12
000 furlongs which again is an ancient
british unit of measurement
but probably used way beyond britain
and when we look at the ratio of the
furlong if we took
out in the parking lot here and laid out
a furlong 660 feet
and then marked off one inch on it that
furlong
to that inch would be exactly the same
as the diameter of the earth
to the mile now in
in the book of revelations what it says
is that the new jerusalem
is twelve thousand of these furlongs so
if you take
660 which i put in there
times 12 000
look at the number that comes up again
there's that number again 792.00
but it's been raised by orders of
magnitude yeah divide that
by the number of feet in a mile put the
divide button
okay divide by 5280
divide by 5280
there is what they're describing a body
that's 1500 miles in diameter
right so what is that what is 1500 miles
in diameter
that's the mystery now if you take
that number and i'm going to go to the
earth itself 7920
and divide it by the new jerusalem
divide by
1500 there's the ratio we get
the human pace to the human foot whoa
coincidence or are we beginning to see
that there's an
underlying pattern now five two eight
yeah five to eight so the ratio is there
right i'm not making any of this up
so you either dismiss it as coincidence
or you go okay there's an underlying
pattern here
and it's got some meaning to it now i
think
it's going to be beyond our ability
today to really get into that but
this is the kind of thing when you begin
to peel back these layers you begin to
discover
that there are these ratios built into
this so it's some
in in a sense fractal it's fractal yes
wow and and the idea here just like
protagoras said
that that we humans we're the measure of
of all things and and all of these
cosmic dimensions
are miniaturized and encoded in our very
anatomy
randall carlson we have run out of time
but you have blown minds on multiple
fronts
once again man we got to do another one
when's the next time you tell me uh
uh money's good well give me a few
months to recover from this one
okay you tell me i'm going to bed for a
week now
yeah i'm sure it's quite a burst of
information but thank you sir really
really appreciate it it's always a
pleasure having you here
you're one of my favorite podcast guests
without a doubt i enjoy it so much
and i'm going to go over this podcast
with a fine tooth comb and try to figure
it out i want to say one more quick
thing
a lot of this information that i've been
talking about here is on
our dvd that you can get uh online
cosmic patterns and cycles of
catastrophe where you get all of the
images and a lot of the background and
the stuff that we went into so if you go
to the sacred geometry international
website
you'll be able to find a link and find
out all about it what is the exact
website
sacred geometry geometry international
dot com i guess so if you just put
sacred geometry international in the
search engine it'll be the first thing
that comes up
and google and your twitter handle is
sacred geometry int correct
yeah right yeah is it right hold on a
second i'll check it on the profile real
quick
sacred yeah sacred geo
int okay so sacred geo at sacred geo int
thank you my friend is a massive honor
and a privilege and a
pleasure and i i appreciate this so much
thank you i appreciate you having me joe
listen man you're changing the world
you're changing the world believe me
you're freaking people to [ __ ] out
well you're helping me joe randall
helping me
randall carlson ladies and gentlemen he
will be back in a few months we'll let
him recover we'll send him some vitamin
c
send him some honest supplies we'll get
him back out here thank you brother i
really appreciate it
wow
i don't drink much coffee oh yeah well
if you don't drink much coffee that
stuff will